ASKED THAT WE START TO COMMITTEE
UNTIL SHE GETS HERE.
A COUPLE OF ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SPEAKER HAS APPOINTED THE SOME
OF THEM ARE KEVIN MCCARTY TO
REPLACE THREE OF US TODAY.
AND WE HAVE ONE ITEM FILE ITEM
FIVE SB SEVEN NINETY PROPOSED
CONSENT.
AND WE'LL START WITH THAT SIGN
IN ORDER OUR FIRST AUTHORS HERE
FALLEN FOR SB FIVE THIRTY ONE
CENTER GLAZER.
VERY BEGIN THE SEARCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MISTER ACTING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
FIVE THIRTY ONE SIX TO STOP
PERVERSE INCENTIVES IN OUR
CURRENT TAX CODE THAT HAVE LED
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO GIVE AWAY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN TAX
REVENUE TO PRIVATE COMPANIES.
THESE DEALS TAKE MONEY FROM
EVERY CITY IN THE STATE.
AND GIVE IT TO SOME OF THE
RICHEST CORPORATIONS IN THE
WORLD.
UNDER THE BRADLEY BURNS UNIFORM
UNIFORM LOCAL SALES TAX LAW.
SALES TAX REVENUE IS ALLOCATED
TO THE POINT OF SALE. FOR BRICK
AND MORTAR STORES THIS MEANS
ALLOCATING THE REVENUE TO THE
JURISDICTION THE STORES LOCATED
IN.
ONLINE RETAILERS HOWEVER HAVE
THE ABILITY TO CHOOSE WHERE THEY
ALLOCATE SALES TAX REVENUE.
HE THAT A WAREHOUSE DISTRIBUTION
CENTER OR SALES OFFICE.
THIS ALLOWS COMPANIES TO DIRECT
REVENUE TO A SINGLE JURISDICTION
IN THE STATE.
CORPORATIONS USE THIS AS
LEVERAGE WHEN NEGOTIATING WHERE
TO LOCATE WITHIN CALIFORNIA.
THIS RESULTS IN A RIG PROCESS
DRIVING CITIES TO ACCEPT
INCREASINGLY ONEROUS TAX SHARING
AGREEMENTS.
IN EXCHANGE FOR ONLINE RETAILERS
BUILDING OR RELOCATING IN THEIR
JURISDICTION.
UNDER THESE AGREEMENTS PRIVATE
COMPANIES.
PROFIT FROM BOTH THEIR ON LINE
SALES AND FROM THE SALES TAX
REBATES OFTEN CITIES WILL GIVE
THESE CORPORATIONS MORE THAN
HALF.
OF THEIR SALES TAX REVENUES
ALLOCATED TO THAT JURORS TO
THEIR JURISDICTION.
HE'S COMPANIES BENEFIT AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE PUBLIC.
AT A TIME WHEN CITIES ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND PUBLIC
PROGRAMS.
COMPANIES ARE SIPHONING BILLIONS
IN TAXPAYER DOLLARS THROUGH
THESE AGREEMENTS [inaudible]
FURTHERMORE.
WHILE THESE AGREEMENTS ARE OFTEN
TOUTED FOR CREATING JOBS AND
HAVING SUBSTANTIAL ECONOMIC
BENEFITS.
THESE CLAIMS ARE DUBIOUS IN FACT
IN YOUR ANALYSIS -- TODAY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S AS WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT SPECIFIC ISSUE
THAT THAT SPECIFIC CLAIM.
SOME OF THESE AGREEMENTS DO NOT
REQUIRE THAT THE PROMISE JOBS
ARE EVER CREATED.
AND EVEN WHEN THEY DO.
THE JOB TO THESE WAREHOUSES ARE
OFTEN GRUELING LOW WAGE AND LACK
BENEFITS.
CITIES NEED REAL JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORKING
FAMILIES NOT A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM. FOR THESE REASONS SB
FIVE THIRTY ONE WOULD PROHIBIT
ANY FUTURE SALES TAX SHARING
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND PRIVATE
COMPANIES.
IT HAS NO EFFECT ON ANY EXISTING.
AGREEMENT IT TAKES NO MONEY FROM
ANY CITY.
AND IT DOES NOT REDUCE THE SALES
TAX REVENUE TO ANY CITY CAN
RECEIVE IN THE FUTURE.
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION -- CITIES LIKE
PLACENTIA RANCHO CUCAMONGA AND
COURSE LEAGUE OF CITIES DAN
CHARACTERS HERE REPRESENTING
THEIR POINT OF VIEW.
THANK YOU.
MR -- CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAID JACK
YOU'RE GONNA BE AWFULLY GOOD
CALIFORNIA CITIES -- THE
CONTENTS OF THIS BILL ARE
CONSISTENT WITH -- IS A
RECOMMENDATION FROM A LEAGUE
SUCH HOUSE FORCE WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT ISSUES RELATED TO
BRADLEY BURNS INTERNET.
OF COMMERCE -- SOME OF THE
CHANGES -- IN ORDER -- TO TO OUR
TO OUR REVENUES -- CAUSED BY YOU
COMMERCE AND THOSE TRENDS --
CONTINUING. ONE OF THE THINGS
ARE OR ARE WORKING GROUP BUT YOU
COLLUDED CITY MANAGERS FROM A
VARIETY OF OF CITIES AROUND THE
STATE RECOMMENDED IS THEY FELT
THAT THESE THESE TYPES OF
AGREEMENTS INDEPTH CONSOLIDATING.
A REVENUE IN ONE LOCATION OUGHT
TO BE A BAND PROSPECTIVELY AND
AS THE AUTHOR SAID OF IT DOESN'T
AFFECT ANY EXISTING AGREEMENTS --
IT STILL ALLOWS COMMUNITIES TO
USE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT WITH
THEIR OWN REVENUES -- AND SOME
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE WOULD
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO SHOW WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE ANGIE MINETTI HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF FRESNO
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL -- ALTHOUGH THE BILL
DOES GRANDFATHER IN EXISTING
AGREEMENTS -- WHICH WE HAVE
THREE AGREEMENTS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL -- BUT WE STILL CONTINUE
TO OPPOSE THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
WE HAVE EXPERIENCED TREMENDOUS
ECONOMIC REVITALIZATION THROUGH
THE USE OF THESE TAX SHARING
AGREEMENTS -- AND HAVE EVEN
DRAWN BUSINESS AWAY FROM OTHER
STATES BECAUSE OF THE
COMPETITIVE NATURE OF THESE
TYPES OF AGREEMENTS -- THESE ARE
NOT CORPORATE GIVEAWAYS WE
ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR CONTRACTS
ARE.
JOB BASED -- WE OFFER INCENTIVES
THAT ARE DIRECTLY CONNECTED TO
FULL -- FULL TIME JOBS WITH
BENEFITS AND HAVE DIFFERENT ON
SKILLS THAT STEP DOWN FROM THAT
AS WELL.
I THINK I AM YOU KNOW WHAT'S
BEEN PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT WITH --
BUT IT WITH THIS ISSUE IS THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW THERE ARE
DIFFERENT REGIONS OF THE STATE
THAT HAVE INHERENT ADVANTAGES.
YET IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY THERE
ARE VERY SPECIFIC STRUGGLES
RELATED TO JUST OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE -- ARE POVERTY RATES AS
WELL AND SO WE'VE TAKEN IT UPON
OURSELVES TO PURSUE -- THIS TYPE
OF TAX SHARING AGREEMENT TO BE
COMPETITIVE AND ATTRACT THOSE
TYPES OF JOBS FOR OUR REGION.
AS A RESULT OF THE THREE CENTERS
THAT WE HAVE IN FRESNO WE HAVE
UP TOWARDS FOUR THOUSAND NEW
JOBS THOSE WHICH HAVE BEEN --
TAKEN BY WELL FORMER WELFARE TO
WORK RECIPIENTS -- OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE HAS GONE FROM
DOUBLE DIGITS TO SINGLE DIGITS
NOW WHICH IS -- WHICH IS A
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS -- WE BELIEVE.
WHAT I THINK THAT IT WHAT THE
POLICY QUESTION THAT THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO ADDRESS IS -- YOU
KNOW A LITTLE BIT UNFOUNDED WE
WE DON'T REALLY SEE HOW THESE
TAX SHARING AGREEMENTS THAT HAVE
BENEFITTED DISADVANTAGED THESE.
ARE NOW COMING TO A PLACE WHERE
YOU KNOW THERE ARE THE WHERE
WHERE WE NEED TO COMPLETELY
PROHIBIT THEM -- YOU KNOW WE DO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND
THE MAYOR FRESNO BACK WHEN HE
WAS A COUNCIL MEMBER MEMBER DID
PASS ORDINANCES TO DO SO AND SO.
WE WOULD URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE TODAY AND PRESERVE OUR
ABILITY TO EXERCISE OUR LOCAL
CONTROL AND OFFER THESE TYPES OF
INCENTIVES MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU TO SHOW WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MICHELLE WELCOME ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF PARIS ALSO
UNFORTUNATELY STILL OPPOSED TO
SB FIVE THIRTY ONE A CITY OF
PARIS IS A VERY SMALL TOWN.
SOUTH OF LOS ANGELES AND VERY
FLAT DOESN'T.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF AVENUES TO
CREATE DEVELOPMENT IN OUR CITY
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO USE HIS
ACTION AGREEMENTS TO GROW.
OUR SMALL CITY AND FACT BEFORE
THESE TEXTURE INTERMENTS WERE IN
PLACE WE HAD AN UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE OF 16% INNER CITY AND DUE
TO SPECIFICALLY TO THIS TAX
RETURN AS WE'VE BEEN ABLE.
TO REDUCE THAT TO SIX POINT 7%
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IN ADDITION SOME OF THE
JOBS THAT HAVE BEEN CREATED BY
THE SEA COMMERCENTRE IS PAY
UPWARDS OF FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR.
I ALMOST OF TWO TWENTY FIVE
DEPENDING ON THE PARTICULAR JOB
POSITION THERE'S ALSO SOME
MANAGERIAL JOBS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE THE PAY.
IN EXCESS OF SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR IT IS BEEN -- A
LIFESAVING TOOL FOR THE CITY OF
PARIS UP UNTIL VERY RECENTLY
THEY'VE STRUGGLED WITH
GENERATIONAL POVERTY AND TO BE
HONEST WE WE UNDERSTAND AND BE
WILLING TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT TAX YOU AGREEMENTS AND
MAYBE SOME OF THE CONCERNS.
AND HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT
THE ELIMINATION OF ON WORD AND
FORWARD GOING TAX CHURNING
REMAINS DOES PUT THE CITY OF
PARIS IN A POSITION WHERE IT
PLACES A GLASS CEILING ABOVE
THEIR HEAD AND WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GRANDFATHER
CLAUSE WHICH WILL.
KEEP SOME OF OUR EXISTING
AGREEMENTS ATTACK BUT IT IS
BASICALLY TELLING US THAT THERE
WILL BE NO ADDITIONAL GROWTH FOR
OUR PARTICULAR CITY FOR THAT
REASON WE'RE OPPOSED.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
KEEP TELLING YOU HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
HERE AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
WE DO APPRECIATE THAT WE ARE
GRANDFATHERING IN UNDER THE BILL
EXISTING AGREEMENTS BUT I THINK
THAT I WOULD JUST CAUTION THAT
ELIMINATION OF THEM OUT RIGHT
WILL AND DEFINITELY HAVE AN
IMPACT IN.
CALIFORNIA IT'S AN ECONOMIC TOOL
FULL GOVERNMENTS TO UTILIZE
ATTRACTING BUSINESS -- IN
LOCATION IS IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
DECIDING WHETHER COME TO
CALIFORNIA AT ALL OREGON STATE
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEING ON A BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MR CORP YUP WAREHOUSE JOBS IN
PARTICULAR.
ARE CITED.
NEAR WHERE THE DELIVERIES ARE
GOING TO BE MADE.
MAYBE INSTEAD OF GOING TO FRESNO
IT MIGHT HAVE GONE TO A NEARBY
CITY.
BUT EITHER WAY THE JOBS ARE
AVAILABLE IN THE REGION.
ALL WE'RE DOING HERE IS LOSING
TAX MONEY -- AND ONCE YOU START
THIS ALL THE OTHER CITIES HAVE
TO COMPETE.
IN THE END NOBODY HAS A
PARTICULAR ADVANTAGE.
SO I I JUST DO NOT AGREE WITH
THE OPPOSITION.
ARTS CENTER GLAZIER THIS IS ONE
OF THE BEST BILLS I'VE EVER SEEN
IN REVENUE TAX.
IF YOU ARE HAPPEN -- TO BE
TAKING AMENDMENTS TO GET ON THE
BILL AT SOME POINT I'D LOVE TO
BE CO AUTHOR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE SENATOR GLAZERS
REALLY CLOSE.
I JUST THANK YOU FOR THE
CONSIDERATION ALL THE CITIES
THAT FOR THAT THAT OVER HERE
TODAY THEY THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
MAKE THESE AGREEMENTS.
THEY JUST CAN'T READ ME DATE THE
MONEY.
BACK TO THE COMPANIES THEY CAN
USE THEIR TAX REVENUE FROM LOTS
OF OTHER SOURCES TO TO TRY.
TO ATTRACT BUT I CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK THAT --
IT'S PLAN PEOPLE AGAINST EACH
OTHER IN THE LOSERS OF THE
PUBLIC -- THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
AND THEIR ECONOMIC ANALYSIS SAID
THAT -- THAT WE GIVE AWAY A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THAT
WOULD NORMALLY GO TO PUBLIC
AGENCIES CITIES AND COUNTIES. TO
THOSE COMPANIES IN THESE DEALS
THINK ABOUT THAT A BILLION
DOLLARS THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
GRAB BACK -- BECAUSE THEY WHAT
THEY DO THEY SAID WE'LL WE'LL
MOVE TEN MILES DOWN THE ROAD --
AND AND CAN COME TO YOUR TOWN
AND THAT'S THAT'S PLAN AGAINST
EACH OTHER THAT'S A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM.
BELIEVE ME I LOVED ELIMINATE
THESE ENTIRELY BUT THIS IS A
SMALL STEP FORWARD TO TRY TO NOT
MAKE IT WORSE AND I APPRECIATE
THAT SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER WILL TAKE THAT
ITEM UP ONLY GET A QUORUM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL.
HEAR FILE ITEM ONE SB FORTY
THREE BY CENTER I'LL.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- WE APPRECIATE. TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TALK ABOUT
THIS BILL AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF -- FOR ITS
WORK ON THE BILL.
I'M SO THIS BILL REQUIRES OUR
AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO SUBMIT A
REPORT ON THE FEASIBILITY AND
PRACTICALITY.
OF CALCULATING THE CARBON
INTENSITY OF RETAIL PRODUCTS.
THAT ARE CURRENTLY SUBJECT IN
SALES AND USE TAX.
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA SO -- OUR
CURRENT MY MIDDLE PROGRAMS SUCH
AS CAP AND TRADE -- PLAY AN
INTEGRAL ROLE IN REDUCING
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THERE ARE A WIDE ARRAY OF
FACTORS THAT.
INFLUENCE CONSUMER PRICES THAT
OFTEN MASK THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
OF THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM.
AND CONSUMERS IN MANY RESPECTS
ARE UNABLE TO SAVE MONEY BY
CHOOSING KARMIC CLIMATE FRIENDLY
ALTERNATIVES THIS IS A ONLY A
STUDY BILL -- BUT I I DO THINK
IT WOULD HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND -- THE THE CHALLENGES
THE OPPORTUNITIES THE DOWNSIDES
THE UP SIDES OF OF THE
FEASIBILITY THE PRACTICALITY OF
DETERMINING TYPE CARBON
INTENSITY WHICH WOULD YOU KNOW
COULD MAYBE ONE DAY.
REPLACE THE STATE SALES AND USE
TAX WITH THE REVENUE NEUTRAL --
CARBON PRIVATE PRICING MECHANISM
BASED ON THE CARBON.
INTENSITY OF AN INDIVIDUAL
PRODUCT AND WE'VE BEEN HAVING
VERY PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
THOSE IN OPPOSITION. TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS AND I ACTUALLY DO
BELIEVE NOW THAT WITH ALL THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE TAKE IN --
THE OPPOSITION ALL OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL HAS BEEN REMOVED -- I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY IS ABOUT
GONZALEZ POTTER FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY CHRISTINE SHOEMAKER
FROM BASEL FREE CALIFORNIA.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANKS FOR HAVING US MISTER BY
STERN MEMBERS MANY AS HE'S
AVAILABLE SALAS PART IN POLLY'S
POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY.
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IS THE
LARGEST ENVIRONMENTAL NONPROFIT
IN THE WORLD WITH OFFICES IN ALL
FIFTY STATES HERE IN THE U. S.
AS WELL AS IN SEVENTY TWO
COUNTRIES.
THE CONSERVANCY RECOGNIZES THE
ONGOING NEED TO CURB EMISSIONS
AS WE FACE THE GREATEST
EXISTENTIAL CRISIS OF OUR TIME
CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THIS MEASURE IS A STUDY
BILL AS THE GOOD CENTER HAS SAID.
MEANT TO PROVIDE THE STATE WITH
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT MAY
INFORM THE DISCUSSION ON HOW WE
COULD POTENTIALLY REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS EVEN
FURTHER.
SPECIFICALLY BY REQUIRING CARBS
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION WHETHER
THERE ARE FEASIBLE AND PRACTICAL
MECHANISMS FOR ASSESSING AND
ASSIGNING.
CARBON INTENSITY TO RETAIL
PRODUCTS SUBJECTS TO THE CEILING
USE TAX LAW.
AT THIS POINT WE NEED ALL THE
INFORMATION WE CAN GET TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE MOST EFFECTIVELY.
THIS SHOULD INCLUDE EXAMINING
THE SALES AND USE TAX AS A
POTENTIAL MECHANISM.
LAST FALL THE INTERGOVERNMENTAL
PANEL ON CLIMATE CHANGE THE I.
P. C. C. ISSUED A REPORT -- THAT
I'M SURE MANY OF YOU ARE
FAMILIAR WITH.
HIGHLIGHTING THE GLOBAL URGENCY
TO BECOME CARBON NEUTRAL IF NOT
CARBON NEGATIVE BY MID CENTURY
TO KEEP OVERALL TEMPERATURES
FROM RISING.
MORE THAN ONE POINT FIVE DEGREES
CELSIUS THIS REPORT FOLLOW THE
PARIS AGREEMENT WHERE COUNTRIES
COMMITTED TO KEEP TEMPERATURES
WELL BELOW TWO DEGREES CELSIUS.
AS COMPARED TO PRE INDUSTRIAL
TEMPERATURES. TO AVOID THE MOST
CATASTROPHIC IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A LEADER ON THE
CLIMATE FRONT BUT WE WILL NEED
TO DO MORE IF WE WANT TO DO OUR
PART. TO HELP ME NOT ONLY THE
PARIS COMMITMENTS AND IPCC
REPORT GUIDANCE.
AT THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WE SEE
SB FORTY THREE AS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO UNDERSTAND TO THE VIABILITY
AND EFFECTIVENESS OF ANOTHER
TOOL.
THIS TIME FOCUSED ON CONSUMERS
TO HELP US IN THIS EFFORT AND
REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND POTENTIALLY OUTSIDE ITS
BORDERS.
WE ARE JST PART FOR THIS BILL
SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND WHETHER
CHANGES TO THE SALES AND USE TAX
COULD BE PART OF THE SOLUTION
THANKS FOR TIME.
THANK YOU.
SO -- ACTING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE SHOEMAKER I'M A
RETIRED PLANT MOLECULAR
BIOLOGISTS IN A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF FOSSIL FOR
CALIFORNIA.
ALSO FOR CALIFORNIA'S A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION HAS OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND ONLINE SUPPORTERS
WHICH WORKS TO LIMIT -- CLIMATE
DAMAGING FOSSIL FUELS AND
PROMOTED JUST TRANSITION TO A
LOW CARBON ECONOMY -- THIS BILL
FITS WITH OUR MISSION THE
PROBLEM CLIMATE CHANGE AS MY
COLLEAGUE HAS SAID IS AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT.
AND WE NEED -- FAST DRAWDOWNS
AND A MULTI PRONGED APPROACH.
IF WE'RE GOING TO GET TO A LOW
CARBON ECONOMY WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE COMPANY IS
IN THE ECONOMY.
SO THE CARBON INTENSITY
DETERMINATION -- IS THAT AND IT
NEEDS TO BE CONSISTENT AND
STANDARD AND ACCURATE.
AND CARP HAS BASICALLY ALREADY
DONE THIS ALREADY FOR THE FUELS
IN THE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD.
SO IT FITS WITH THEIR EXPERTISE
TO SEE IF IT'S FEASIBLE TO
DETERMINE THE CARBON INTENSITY
OF ALL THE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO THE SALES AND USE TAX --
WE THINK THAT PASSING THIS
MESSAGE PASSING THIS ALL.
ON BILL WOULD SEND A STRONG
MESSAGE TO MANUFACTURERS AND
CONSUMERS ALIKE THAT THE CARBON
TEN CITY OF PRODUCTS -- MADE
SOLD AND BOUGHT IN CALIFORNIA
ARE IMPORTANT TO THE STATE AND
THEY FIT WITH THE STATE'S OF
GOALS.
ADDITIONALLY -- IF IT CAME BACK
THAT THIS WAS FEASIBLE THEN THE
NEXT STEP WOULD BE VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WOULD BE.
DETERMINING CARBON INTENSITY FOR
A VARIETY OF PRODUCTS THAT ARE
OUT THERE IS SOMETHING THAT'S
DEFINITELY NEEDED INFORMATION
THAT WOULD BE GOOD BOTH FOR THE
MANUFACTURERS.
AND THE CONSUMERS -- IF OF IT
WOULD BE USEFUL FOR CONSUMERS
LEGISLATORS AND REGULATORS ALIKE
TO UNDERSTAND AND MAKE BETTER
AND SMARTER ENVIRONMENTAL
DECISIONS.
AND WE WOULD BE GOOD FOR THE
PUBLIC AS WELL SO WHAT WE URGE
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BECAUSE WE
DO FEEL THAT -- TO MEASURE WE
NEED TO MEASURE AND LIMIT CARBON
LIKE OUR PLANET DEPENDS ON IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
LOOK AT US HERE ON BEHALF OF
STOP WASTE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ROSALIE ROTH SACRAMENTO THREE
FIFTY IN SUPPORT ALSO SILICON
VALLEY THREE FIFTY ALSO SELF BAY
LA.
THREE FIFTY THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE
OF THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WAS QUIRK
[inaudible]
CHAU [inaudible]
AMAZON.
CELLS TWELVE MILLION PRODUCTS
NOT INCLUDING BOOKS MEDIA WINE
AND SERVICES.
WHEN AMAZON MARKETPLACE SELLERS
ARE FACTORY AND THE TOTAL
PRODUCT COUNT THIS IS SEPARATE
ES QUE USE?
BALLOONS TO MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE MILLION AND
THAT'S JUST AMAZON THEIR OTHER
SELLERS AS WELL ON THE WEB AND
RETAIL.
HOW CAN WE POSSIBLY [inaudible]
DETERMINE -- THE CARBON CONTENT.
FOR HALF A BILLION PRODUCTS.
YOU KNOW WE WE TRY OUR BEST I
MEAN -- IN THE END OF THE DAY --
THIS IS ABOUT.
REALIZING THE FACT THAT WE'VE
GOT AN EXISTENTIAL CRISIS ON OUR
HANDS WHOM IS CHALLENGE.
AND THEN -- AND THEN BASICALLY
TASKING A GROUP THAT HAS BEEN
WORKING REALLY INTENSELY IN THIS
AREA FOR A LONG TIME.
WITH -- WITH THE WITH A
RESPONSIBILITY IN A ROLE TO TO
TO TO TRY ITS BEST.
AND AS I SAY IF THEY COME BACK
WITH A WITH A MECHANISM OR THEY
IF THEY SAY THIS IS IMPOSSIBLE
IT'S ON FEASIBLE.
WE WALK AWAY FROM THE ISSUE WE
DON'T PURSUE IT FURTHER BUT I DO
THINK THAT -- THERE ARE LOTS OF
DIFFERENT IF YOU LOOK AT AT ALL
SORTS OF PRICING MECHANISMS OF
YOU LOOK YOU LOOK AT THE VA T.
SYSTEM IN EUROPE I MEAN IF YOU
WOULD HAVE FIRST SUGGESTED DOING
THAT THAT WAS SOUNDED PRETTY
COUPLE NOTED THE V. A. T. IS
JUST VALUE ADDED.
YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S ADDED
EACH DAY H. PRICES QUITE A
PROCESS.
WITH [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SO -- WE WE WE WE WE WE
BASICALLY TASK THEM WITH WITH
TAKING A LONG HARD LOOK AT THIS.
AND THEY'LL BE LOOKING AT MODELS
ALL OVER THE WORLD -- YOU KNOW
NETHERLANDS HAVE BEEN WORKING IN
THIS AREA [inaudible]
AND AND THEY COME BACK TO US
WITH WITH THIS WITH WITH A
SERIES OF FINDINGS WELL.
LET ME JUST SAY MY SON DID HIS
THESIS WORK.
ON LEDS VERSUS FLUORESCENT BULBS
AND LOOKING AT THE LIFE CYCLE.
THAT TOOK MONTHS OF WORK.
AND NOW YOU'VE GOT HALF A
BILLION PRODUCTS AYE AYE
PERMISSION TO USE.
A PROP WITHOUT OBJECTION ALL
RIGHT SO THE ISSUE IS CURRENTLY
MADE IN THE U. S..
SHOULD SHOULD THE THE
MANUFACTURER DECIDED TO
OUTSOURCE TO CHINA [inaudible]
OR MALAYSIA [inaudible]
OR BOTH -- IT'LL HAVE A VERY
DIFFERENT CARBON FOOTPRINT I
JUST DON'T THINK THIS IS
PRACTICAL.
GO AHEAD THROUGH THE CHAIR I I I
WILL SAY -- THAT THE BILL.
CALLS ON IDENTIFYING CERTAIN
GROUPS OF PRODUCTS THAT WOULD
ELIMINATE THE MOST EMISSIONS SO
SO IT IT IS VERY LIKELY TO BE
HONEST.
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
SMALLER ITEMS THAT WERE LOOKED
AT THE WOULD JUST DESCRIBE WHAT
WOULD WOULD BE COVERED VERY
DIFFERENTLY -- MAYBE THERE'D BE
A ANY A LOOK AT THE AT THE
CARBON FOOTPRINT ASSOCIATED WITH
DISTRIBUTION -- BUT BY.
THE BILL BUT BUT THE BILL I I
ANTICIPATES WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT NOT EXPECTING THE AIRPORT
TO GO INTO EVERY [inaudible]
SMALL ITEM --IT'S ABOUT TRYIN
TO MOVE THE MOVE THE NEEDLE.
MON THE MACRO LEVEL RELATING TO
CARBON INTENT SO THE DID THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE CARBON
FOOTPRINT OF ETHANOL FOR USE IN
VEHICLES.
HAS BEEN DEBATED FOR YEARS IT'S
STILL THE SUBJECT OF LAWSUITS.
I JUST DON'T SEE HOW THIS CAN BE
DONE.
IF SOME IF YOU ARE YOU ONE OF
YOUR EXPERTS WOULD LIKE.
TO ANSWER I I JUST DON'T SEE WAY
TO DO IT.
WELL I WOULD DO DID YOU WANT TO
I MEAN I I WOULD SAY THAT WE TRY
OUR BEST WITH ALL THESE KINDS OF
THINGS RIGHT I MEAN HOW YOU KNOW
THAT THEIR THERE ARE ALL SORTS
OF ESTIMATES THAT WE USE.
TO ESTIMATE EMISSIONS RIGHT WE
WE WE TRY OUR BEST AND WE
NOTHING IS PERFECT -- BUT TO SAY
THAT.
THAT IT'S AN IMPERFECT SCIENCE
AND THAT THAT SHOULD MEAN THAT
WE DON'T DO ANYTHING IN THIS
AREA I THINK WOULD BE A BIG
MISTAKE GIVEN THE SIZE AND
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH --
WITH CARBON IMPACTING CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND SO AS I SAY.
WE GOT SOME SMART PEOPLE OVER
THE AIR BOARD -- WE WOULD WE
WOULD TASK THEM WITH TRYING TO
COME UP WITH SOME SORT OF
FEASIBLE.
MECHANISM IF BEING HOME BACK TO
US AND SAY YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO DO THIS SO WE WE WE JUST
IT'S TOO IMPRACTICAL IT'S TOO
AND FEASIBLE.
THAT WE DON'T PURSUE IT OKAY
THANK YOU.
DIGITAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
MISS PETRIE-NORRIS.
YOU MENTIONED AT THAT SOME OTHER
COUNTRIES HAVE STARTED TO TAKE
SOME DECENT STEPS IN THIS
DIRECTION CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT
READ MORE AND PERHAPS TALK ABOUT
HOW THEY'VE MADE.
ARE THERE SOME PRACTICAL
EXAMPLES WHERE WE'VE GOTTEN
TRACTION WITH THIS KIND OF
APPROACH.
YES OF THE NETHERLANDS IS IS FOR
THE MOST ADVANCED IN THIS AREA
AND THEY HAVE -- YOU KNOW
CREATED THIS.
THE SYSTEM THAT WE CAN GET YOU
SOME INFORMATION THE OECD'S BEEN
BEEN REPORTING ON THIS BUT THEY
BASICALLY GO THROUGH -- THROUGH
SECTORS AND THE LOOK AT CARBON
EMISSIONS AND THEN THEY THEY'LL
THEY'LL GO THROUGH AND AND KIND
OF DO A DEEP DIVE INTO EACH
OTHER SECTORS AND AND LOOK AT
PRODUCTS.
WE NEED EACH OF THOSE SECTORS
WHERE THEY CAN MOVE THE NEEDLE
THE MOST -- AND AND SO I I'M NOT
A EXPERT IN THEIR PRICING SYSTEM --
I DON'T KNOW IF ONE OF THE TWO
NEW CAPS AND CONDITIONAL
THOUGHTS ON THE WAY THEY
STRUCTURE WE CAN CERTAINLY GET
YOU INFORMATION AS TO THE MOLLEN
BASE STRUCTURED -- BUT THEY YOU
KNOW THEY THEY BUT BUT WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE IS IS I I KNOW THEIR
FOCUS KIND OF GETTING BACK TO
THE EARLIER QUESTION NEED TO
REALLY FOCUS IN ON I AND 80% OF
CAR OF CO TWO EMISSIONS.
AS OPPOSED TO EVERY PRODUCT
RIGHT THERE THEY'RE NOT SPENDING
ALL THEIR TIME.
ON AND ON THE ON THE HIGH
HANGING FRUIT IT'S ALL ABOUT THE
IT'S IT'S ABOUT THE BITS ABOUT
WHERE MOST OF THE PROBLEM IS AND
REALLY FOCUSING IN ON THOSE
KINDS OF ITEMS AND PRODUCTS.
BECAUSE IT WRAPS THE RIGHT WE
CAN'T WHICH WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SIT HERE AND YOU KNOW I I AND
AND AND FIGURE OUT A MECHANISM
FOR FOR PRICING.
EVERY MINISCULE ITEM.
AND IN THE IN A THAT WOULD BE A
WASTE OF OUR TIME AND OUR
RESOURCES THERE ARE CERTAIN
PRODUCTS THAT THAT ARE THAT ARE
REALLY.
CAUSING THE MOST DAMAGE IN TERMS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AYE AYE THE
SUN MEMBER BETWEEN OURS I CAN
SHARE WITH YOU.
THIS CHART HERE -- SURE THOSE
ABOUT THE SYSTEM THAT THEY WERE
NOT WAITING FOR ANYONE ELSE AT
THIS TIME OKAY.
HERE TAKE A LOOK.
IF THE CHAIR IS OKAY.
ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
YEAH THIS IS IT.
WELL ON THE FIRST PAGE ANYWAY
IT'S INFORMATION WE ALREADY HAVE
LIKE WHICH INDUSTRIES ARE MOST
CARBON INTENSIVE.
AND AS FAR AS MANUFACTURING GOES
WE ALSO KNOW WHICH ONES ARE MOST
COMMON IN.
MOST CARBON INTENSIVE
PARTICULARLY -- MAKING CONCRETE
AND CEMENT RIGHT EYES ONE OF THE
BIGGEST IN THE INDUSTRY -- AND
THEREFORE TWENTY OF OUR BIG
TARGETS.
ANYWAY ALL RIGHT WELL THAT'S
YEAH THEIR ATTENTION YEAH THAT'S
MEANT AND THE THING IS WE'RE
ALREADY DOING THAT SO.
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR
BECAUSE WE ALREADY LOOK AT YOU
KNOW IN THE INDUSTRIES
PARTICULARLY SAMANTHA.
OF WHAT ARE THE BIGGEST --
IMPACTORS AND WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT AND THEY HAVE TO
PAY ALREADY A CARBON TAX FOR
THAT. FOR THE CO TWO THEY
GENERATE.
AND IN GENERAL FOR THE
INDUSTRIES HERE IN THE US IF
THEY'RE GENERATING CO -- TWO AT
LEAST IN CALIFORNIA WERE KEEPING
TRACK OF THAT -- AND THEN IT
BECOMES VERY COMPLEX AS WE DO
CAP AND TRADE BUT THIS IS.
THIS JUST GOES WAY BEYOND THAT
MAYBE OR MAYBE NOT I'M JUST NOT
SURE EXACTLY THE LEVEL OF DETAIL.
AND WOULD YOU SAY YOUR BILL
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO DETERMINE
THE LEVEL OF DETAIL THEY GO INTO.
OUR EXTENT YES -- BETTY BUT I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
REPLACING THE SALES TAX WHICH IS
ON EVERY ITEM.
REST IF I READ YOUR BILL CORRECT
ALL IDEA WOULD BE IF IF IF IT
TURNS OUT THAT THERE IS THERE IS
THERE IS A THERE THERE WITH
REGARDS TO THIS STUDY.
THE IDEA IS THAT WE COULD LOOK
INTO THE POSSIBILITY OF GETTING
RID OF SOUTHEAST TAX ALTOGETHER.
AND REPLACING IT WITH A REVENUE
NEUTRAL.
TAX ASSOCIATE WITH CARBON
INTENSITY.
I JUST.
THAT THEY'RE A LOT AT OF OF OPEN
QUESTIONS RIGHT I MEAN IF IF IF.
IF YOU ARE WORST FEARS PROOF
FOUNDED.
AND THIS ENDS UP BEING TOTALLY
IMPRACTICAL UNTIL YOU FEASIBLE.
YEAH THE ANSWER BACK AS HEY YOU
KNOW LOVE THE IDEA LOVE THE KIND
OF GENERAL CONCEPT BUT THE OTHER
DAY THIS IS NOT GOING TO ONE ON
THE GROUND IN TERMS
IMPLEMENTATION OKAY I KNOW THIS
BUT I WILL SAY THE HOUSE THE
SEXES IS IS.
SO MUCH BIGGER THAN CAP AND
TRADE I MEAN IT CAPITA RAISES
[inaudible]
VERY SMALL -- BUT BUT THE OTHER
IDEA HERE IS THAT WE WOULD NOT
RAISE TAXES ON TO SAY THIS WOULD
THIS WOULD BE REVENUE NEUTRAL
WOULD BE GETTING RID.
OF AN ENTIRE [inaudible]
TAX ALTOGETHER.
IF YOU DO IT BY INDUSTRY GROUPS.
THEN HOW TO PEOPLE YOU KNOW YOU
GOT TO BUY A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
CEMENT NO MATTER WHAT.
THERE'S ALREADY -- CALCULATIONS
FOR LOCAL CEMENT COMPANIES.
I DON'T KNOW HOW IT WORKS OUT
WITH CAP AND TRADE BUT IF WE DO
BY INDUSTRY GROUPS THEN THERE'S
NO REAL SUBSTITUTION OF
AVAILABLE SO I'M NOT SURE.
THAT THIS WOULD DO ANY GOOD.
ANYWAY I JUST HAVE LOTS OF
QUESTIONS.
IF THAT POINT YOU HAVE TO THEN
GO INTO -- INTO KIND F SPECIFIC
ITEMS WITHIN THE INDUSTRY BUT
THE BUT THE POINT BEING YOU'RE
GONNA FOCUS ON THOSE INDUSTRIES
THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST INTENSITY.
NUMBER YOU CAN REALLY FOCUS YOUR
ATTENTION FIRST.
OF THEIR SOME THIS THIS A
MINISTRY THAT GET COUNTERFEITING
YOU 20%.
OF EMISSIONS I'VE YOU'RE GONNA
YOU'RE GONNA REALLY DIG IN ON
THOSE KINDS OF THAT SORT OF
INDUSTRY THAN BEEN WAY OUT SO WE
FIVE SAMANTHA WIND.
ALSO FUELS IS ANOTHER WERE
ALREADY DOING WORK ON THOSE BIG
ISSUES I'M NOT SURE.
THAT TAKING A LOOK AT SHOOTERS
FOR EXAMPLE NOW WE WE CAN RATE
THEM IN TERMS OF THE AMOUNT OF
ELECTRICITY THEY DO AND I THINK
THEY'RE ALREADY DOING THAT.
FOR A LOT OF ITEMS THAT DO USE
ELECTRICITY I JUST DON'T SEE
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE GONNA.
REALLY BE ABLE TO INCENTIVIZE OR
FOR THIS -- BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE WHOLE LIFE CYCLES
CAN BE VERY HARD TO DETERMINE.
YOU KNOW IN CHINA HOW MUCH
CARBON USE THERE IS TO MAKE THIS
LAPTOP VERSUS BAT LAPTOP.
RIGHT TO THE EXTENT THAT -- THAT
THERE ARE BOARDS ARE DONE A LOT
OF WORK IN THIS AREA ACTUALLY
WILL BE LESS COSTLY THAN HAD
BEEN INITIALLY ANTICIPATED.
I'M IN FACT I KNOW THAT THE
LATEST AND YEAH ESTIMATES FOR
THE BECAUSE THIS BILL OF DROPPED
SIGNIFICANTLY I THINK IT'S
PARTLY HAVING TO DO WITH WHAT
YOU'VE JUST TALKED ABOUT THIS IN
WORDS ARE YOU HAPPY.
AREA -- MEDIATOR THE DAY THIS IS
ABOUT TRYING.
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT EVERYTHING
YOU'VE JUST DESCRIBED MMHM AND
SEE IF THERE IS A WAY. TO TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IN A FEASIBLE
PRACTICAL WAY.
CURRENT THANK YOU ANSWER IS NO
YEAH WE WE DON'T MOVE ANY WE
DON'T FEEL FOR WITH IT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
I KNOW THAT DID YOU WANT.
TO WELL I WAS JUST GONNA SAY.
AS FAR AS INDUSTRIES TO LOOK AT
BEYOND CEMENT AND COMPUTERS
THERE ARE OTHERS OUT THERE SUCH
AS FABRICS SHOES HOUSEWARES.
THE LIKE IN THE PEOPLE WERE
LOOKING AT THE LOOK OF LIFE
CYCLE ANALYSIS OF THAT THEY
MIGHT BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY.
POINT SIX CENTER THAT YOU WOULD.
DEAL WITH THE PROBLEM IS MOST OF
THOSE ARE GENERATED ARE MADE
OVERSEAS THE ONES PARTICULAR
FABRIC.
AND IT'S GONNA BE VERY HARD TO
REALLY GET A RELIABLE NUMBER.
THAT COULD BE TRUE AYE AYE I YES
MA'AM IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT.
THE LAW A LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD WHICH THEY HAD
DETERMINED SOME OF THE CARBON
INTENSITY ON SOME OF THAT
ACTUALLY IS COMING FROM
DEFINITELY COMING FROM OUT OF
STATE -- SURE SEES BUT THEN
THAT'S HAVE LAWSUIT TO TED
STUDIES FOR YEARS IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO THIS.
IT IS A MAJOR RESEARCH PROJECT
[inaudible]
AND FOR I'M JUST SKEPTICAL A WE
CAN DO IT BE THAT TACK.
THAT ONE INTO THE DEAD DID YOU
ACTUALLY ABLE TO DETERMINE THAT
THE ISSUE USES LESS CARBON THE
NATURAL.
YOU CAN DETERMINE MAYBE THEY
CHOOSE USE LESS CARBON THEN ARE
MORE CARBON THAN -- PHILIP FLOPS
YOU COULD PROBABLY DO THAT BUT
ANYWAY IJUST I THINK I'VE I
THINK WE DISCUSSED IT AS MUCH AS
WE CAN.
TOTALLY GET YOUR POINT -- I THIS
A BILL BE LOOKING INTO ALL THESE
KINDS OF ISSUES -- BUT BUT YOU
KNOW.
IF YOU EITHER I GUESS ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE POINTS IS IS THAT.
IF WE IF WE DO HAVE A STATICALLY
ONE OWN COURAGE MORE OF ONE ITEM
THAT IS LOCAL LAST CAR WRITTEN
OTHER.
RIGHT NOW THE SALES AND USE TAX
IS JUST.
THE SAME AMOUNT FOR EVERYTHING
REGARDLESS.
HI AND MAYBE THERE OUGHT TO BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF A NEXUS.
OKAY WELL I SHOULD LET YOU GO.
THIS IS THE STUDY IT'S JUST A
STUDY.
AND I I THINK IT'S A WORTHWHILE.
IT'S A WORTHWHILE STUDY.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN AND I HAVE JUST A QUICK.
THEY JUST GOT HERE I THOUGHT I'D
SAY SOMETHING -- I I I KNOW IT'S
JUST A STUDY I JUST MY ONLY
CONCERN IS THAT -- SALES TAX AND
USE TAX IS GENERALLY REGRESSIVE.
AND ALTHOUGH THIS IS JUST A
STUDY I AM SUPER CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT THE FUTURE LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD BE DERIVED FROM THIS KIND
OF BILL AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
I AM ON RECORD AND AND THAT WE
YOU AND I FOLLOW UP AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHATEVER.
LEGISLATION YOU DO PERCEIVE TO
COME FROM THIS -- IS VERY VERY
AWARE THAT IT'S COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE THAT SO OFTEN END UP TAKING
THE BURDEN FOR ISSUES LIKE THIS
AND AND AND THAT WOULD BE OF
GREAT CONCERN FOR ME SO I
UNDERSTAND TO STUDY IN THEIR
GREAT THINGS THAT CAN CAN COME
FROM THE STUDY.
BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
YOU'RE VERY AWARE OF THE
CONCERNS OF MINE AND OF THE
COMMITTEE UNTIL YOU GET IT AND
IN PART -- WE DISCUSSED IS THAT
IS THAT.
IF IT WERE TO BE FOUND AND
THERE'S SOME VERY THERE WITH
REGARD TO THIS WORK. ONE OF THE
IDEAS WOULD BE IN FACT MIKE.
KIND OF FOUGHT COMING INTO THIS
WITH THAT WE WOULD GET RID OF
THE PROGRESSIVE CELLS USE TAX
ALTOGETHER.
AND THAT IT WOULD BE REPLACED
WITH THE REVENUE NEUTRAL -- YEAH
CARBON INTENSITY PRICE RIGHT
THAT THAT COULD BE REGRESSIVE TO
THAT CAME OUT VERY WERE GOING TO
POINT IS THEY'RE BOTH.
LIKE I WE WOULD WE WOULD NOT BE
RAISING TAXES ON SOCIETY.
AND THAT BUT YOU'RE UPS RIGHT
YEAH HOW WOULD WE MAKE SURE TO
ENSURE EXACTLY BECAUSE THAT YES
QUITE OFTEN IT IS.
ALTHOUGH IT WOULD BE REVENUE
NEUTRAL IT IS COMMUNITIES LIKE
MY LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES THAT
WOULD TAKE THE BURDEN ON
SOMETHING THAT WAS WAS I HAD A
CAR HIGHER CARBON IMPACT WE JUST.
YOU KNOW AFFORDABILITY COMES
INTO PLAY AND SO ARE THE END UP
BREAKING IT SO SO JUST SO
SOMEWHERE AT LISTEN YOU AND I
WORK VERY VERY WELL TOGETHER I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE IT'S ON
THE RADAR THAT SOMETIMES THESE
THINGS DO -- END UP COST
ALTHOUGH REVENUE NEUTRAL AND OF
COSTING COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
MORE MAYBE WE OUGHT TO LOOK IT'S
IT'S ADDING ON THE BILL LANGUAGE
THE BILL I WAS.
HAPPY TO THAT MEETING THANK YOU
I'D APPRECIATE IT THINK.
HE WAS IN THE PREVIOUS VERSION
RIGHT I THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT
AND THEN THERE WAS THERE WAS
LANGUAGE IN THE PREVIOUS VERSION
ABOUT LOOKING ABOUT.
IN IMPACTS OF CERTAIN --
CATEGORIES ON ON LOW INCOME CAN
CONSUMERS AND THAT WAS.
IT'S GONE NOW BUT THAT WOULD
DEFINITELY BE SOMETHING TO ADD
BACK THANK YOU KNOW IT CAME OUT
BECAUSE OF TOLL AND RELATED
ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH A
DIFFERENT MECHANISM IN THE BILL
SO LET'S WORK TO GET THAT
LANGUAGE LET'S WORK TO WORKS OF
SUBSIDIES AND THANK YOU.
WE APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU I
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT ROBUST
DISCUSSION AS A STATE.
JUST TAKING A LOOK AT THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND AND HOW WE
MAY.
HAVE A CLOSER NEXUS BETWEEN SOME
OF OUR BROADER CLIMATE GOALS AND
AND CONSUMER BEHAVIOR BUT I
THINK IT'S WORTH SPENDING SOME
TIME LOOKING AT AND AND
CERTAINLY FOR TO WORKING CLOSELY
WITH MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE.
IF THIS BILL IS ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD I HAVE A WITHOUT A
RESPECT FASTER ABOUT THANK YOU
ARE STILL A SUBCOMMITTEE BUT AS
SOON AS WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL
TAKE IT WILL TAKE UP.
THE REGULAR BUSINESS.
THANK YOU -- MOVING TO AND
SENATOR MCGUIRE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB THREE FORTY FOUR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR OF THE TO PROCEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M HONORED TO BE
ABLE TO BE HERE WITH OUR HARD
WORKING STATE TREASURER MISS
YOUR MOM SB THREE FOUR FOUR
PROVIDE A ONE YEAR SUNSET
EXTENSION TO ALLOW.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO COLLECT ON
LOCAL UTILITY USER TAX IS FOR
RETAIL SALES A PREPAID WIRELESS
TELECOMMUNICATION PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES.
PRIOR TO THE PASSAGE OF AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SAID NO WAY NO WAY
FOR COLLECTING LOCAL YOU YOU
TEASE ON PREPAID WIRELESS --
EQUIPMENT AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
ESTABLISH A COLLECTION MECHANISM
SIMILAR TO A SALES TAX WHERE
THEY'RE COVERED APARTMENT TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION COLLECTS
ALL LOCALLY DRIVE UTILITY TAXES
FOR ME TELL SELLS AND
DISTRIBUTES THOSE REVENUES. TO
THE CITY OR COUNTY WHERE THE
PURCHASE TO PLACE BOTTOM LINE IS
THIS IT'S WORTH ABOUT TWENTY
FOUR MILLION.
A HUNDRED ONE CITIES IN THREE
COUNTIES -- COLLECT AND PREPAID
WIRELESS THIS SIMPLY IMPOSES
EIGHT ONE YEAR SUNSET EXTENSION --
IN THERE WILL NEED TO BE
ADDITIONAL CLEAN UP IN THE YEARS
TO COME. TO MY RIGHT IS STATE
TREASURER FREE ON THE MORROW SHE
WAS ABSOLUTELY INSTRUMENTAL --
IN THE RITUAL ESTABLISHMENT OF
THIS APPRECIATE HER HARD WORK WE
AWFUL ALSO NAMED CARED FROM
COPPER LEAGUE CITIES TO BE
INTENSIFIED.
IN SUPPORT OF TURNED OVER THE
WOMAN THE MYTH THE LEGEND TO MY
RIGHT RIGHT WELCOME WELCOME LED
TO AN GOOD -- YES ABOUT THE
SENATE MCGUIRE THANK YOU MEMBERS
AND DAVID ROUGH REMEMBERS HE'S
BEEN HERE THAT LONG WHEN I
CARRIED.
THE INITIAL BILL WHICH IS FOUND
ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS --
BUT BACK THEN -- MANY FOLKS WERE
SWITCHING OVER TO MOBILE PHONES --
LESS PEOPLE HAD LAND MINES AND
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF THE USER
UTILITY TAXES AS WELL AS THE
NINE ONE ONE FEE WAS BEING
COLLECTED.
AND IN ADDITION MANY PEOPLE WERE
BUYING PREPAID PHONE CARDS A AND
NOT PAYING SALES TAX ON THOSE --
COMPANIES OFFERING FREE PHONES
WITH YOU KNOW WIRELESS PLANS AND
NOT COLLECTING THE SALES TAX SO
HENCE THE NECESSITY.
UP FOR THIS BILL -- WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO GET IT OUT OF THE HOUSE
BECAUSE OF PHYSICAL ISSUES AND
WE PEREIRA CARRIED.
A SIMILAR BILL WAS ABLE TO GET
THAT BILL OUT AND THEN NOW
SENATOR MCGUIRE -- SO WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION WERE
ASKING FOR A ONE YEAR SUNSET
EXTENSION SO THAT -- WE CAN ALL
WORK ON IMPLEMENTING OF THE
FEDERAL COURT INJUNCTION -- THAT
WAS RECENTLY PASSED.
SURE MEMBERS SUCH AND KERRY WILL
BE HELPFUL TO GET CALIFORNIA
CITIES APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
CARRYING THE BILL'S WAS THE
TREASURES OF SUPPORT -- YEAH SO
THE AUTHOR SAID THIS BILL ARE
CURRENTLY THERE'S SO A HUNDRED
FOR JURISDICTIONS ARE CURRENTLY
BENEFIT FROM FROM THIS LAW --
WERE RENDERED UP AGAINST A ON A
SUNSET HERE AT THE END OF
DECEMBER -- THE BILL GIVES A ONE
YEAR EXTENSION THERE'S AS THE
ANALYSIS I WHICH IS A GREELEY
GOOD ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THERE'S
A LOT OF COMPLEXITY TO THIS
ISSUE AREA AND SO THEY'LL BE A
MORE -- COMPREHENSIVE -- IT
CLEAN UP TO DEFINITIONS OTHER
THINGS IN A BILL NEXT YEAR --
BUT WE ON ON BEHALF OF THE
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE AFFECTED
THAT HAVE BENEFITTED FROM HE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM RESPECTFULLY.
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THAT STEVE
CARLSON PERCY TI A WE WERE THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL ORIGINALLY
AND WE WENT WAY BACK WITH THE
WITH MS MA WELL BEFORE THAT SHE
SORT OF NURTURED ALONG AND WE WE
THE POLICE THE CITY HERE AND AND
SUPPORT IT AND ASK FOR A NIGHT.
OUT THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME AND
ORGANISED MADAM CHAIR DAVID
JONES BEHALF THE CITY BURBANK
INSTRUCTS PART OF MATTER THANK
YOU.
ANASTASIA KOVALCHUK ON BEHALF OF
CITY OF SACRAMENTO SPORT.
RENDON RYAN WITH MANY SERVICES
AND SUPPORT.
SHEILA MCFARLAND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES SINCE.
MARGARET QUESTION ABOUT
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS IN SUPPORT
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR WORKING
WITH US ON THE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEE LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
WHAT IS AN OPTICAL YOUR
WITNESSES IN THE PARK ONE THAT'S
ALRIGHT?
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SYLVIA SILLY SHAUN
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I WIN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE IF YOU THINK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL THE WORK ON THIS THANK
YOU VERY CAPABLE STAFF INTO THE
TREASURE FOR ALL THEIR WORK --
AS WELL AS A COP IN THE CITY'S
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AT THE MOST PROTECT.
THANK YOU AS SOON AS WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE WILL TAKE IT UP FOR A
VOTE.
AND THEN YOU ALSO HAVE YOUR
COMMITTEE THAT YOU WANT TO DO
THAT NOW FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB.
SEVEN NINETY ONE THE GERMAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR IN
THE LAST THIRTY YEARS THERE HAVE
BEEN VERY FEW ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN MORE CONTENTIOUS IN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR TAX POLICY IN THE ASSESSMENT
OF CERTIFIED AIRCRAFT AT THE ONE
INDIVIDUAL GETS EXCITED ABOUT
THAT IS MISTER RUFF UP OF THE
DICE.
I DURING THIS PERIOD AT COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S IN AIRLINES HAVE
CONTINUOUSLY BEEN AT ODDS WITH
EACH OTHER AND IN THE COURTS AS
WELL AS THE LEGISLATURE AND
TODAY.
WE DO HAVE PEACE IN OUR TIME --
SB SEVEN NINETY ONE REPRESENTS A
CONSCIOUS A CONSENSUS BETWEEN
ASSESSORS AND AIRLINES THAT PUTS
IN PLACE A NEW FORMULA FOR
VALUING AIRCRAFT.
DE GOVERNED BY COMMITTEE
INTRODUCED A BILL WITH THE
APPROVAL OF ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
THE SENATE ALSO APPROVED THE
BILL UNANIMOUSLY LONG STORY
SHORT SB SEVEN NINETY ONE'S NEW
FORMULA ACCOUNTS FOR MODERN
TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN MEASURE ALL
THE TIME AIRCRAFT SPENDS IN THE
STATE DURING THE ENTIRE YEAR.
NOT JUST A REPRESENTATIVE WEEK
UNDER THE OLD LAW.
I'M HAVE WITH ME TODAY WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL OF THE CALIFORNIA
SESSIONS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK
ALONG WITHAIRLINES FOR AMERICA --
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING TOGETHER --
IT IS NOT BEEN AN EASY ISSUE TO
BE ABLE TO RESOLVE IT WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT BOTH ORGANIZATIONS
THE REPRESENTATIVES ARE HERE TO
BE ABLE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
AND ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO CONQUER NOW FROM GOVERNANCE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEES CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR
ALL HIS WORK AND HE HAS TWO
BLACK EYES BECAUSE OF IT.
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THROUGH
THEM AND CHAIR ALL THE WORK THAT
WENT INTO AT THIS IMPORTANT THAT.
THANK YOU -- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ERIC
MICKEY WITH CAPITAL ON POLICY --
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING AIRLINES
FOR AMERICA.
I WANT TO THANK -- THANK THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE FIRST --
SPONSORED THE BILL WERE VERY
STRONG -- SPORES THAT WOULD
ISOLATE THOUGH THANK OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSESSMENT
COMMUNITY THE ASSESSORS FOR
THEIR DILIGENT WORK TO BRING
THIS -- THIS PROBLEM TO A
SUCCESSFUL CONCLUSION IT SHOWS A
PUBLIC POLICY STILL CAN WORK --
I HELPED -- THE WORKING GROUP OF
ASSESSORS AND THE AND THE
INDUSTRY DRAFT SOME OF IT SO IF
THERE'S TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ALL
OF TRY TO ANSWER THIS WITH
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KNOW AND I GOOD
AFTERNOON -- CHAIR BURKE --
JESSE SALINAS COUNT COUNTY
ASSESSOR FOR YOLO COUNTY AND
ALSO OF THE CALIFORNIA SISTERS
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE IN THEIR
BEHALF.
AND WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION AND WE'D LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR MCGUIRE FOR HIS.
DILIGENCE ON THIS HE'S WORKED
HARD ON THIS LEGISLATION OF LONG
AS WELL AS STAFF THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND IT'S REALLY
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WE ARE APPRECIATIVE
OF THE SUPPORT AND ALL THE GOOD
WORK THAT'S GONE INTO IT SO.
WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE ARE JUST SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ROB GROWS
CLOSER WITH THE CALIFORNIA'S.
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL IN THIS IS IN SUPPORT
OF TIM TAYLOR REPRESENTING
AIRLINES FOR AMERICANS.
ADDITIONAL IN THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IF YOU'RE HAVING A GOOD RUN.
I WANT OTHER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR TAKING ON THIS I KNOW THIS
IS BEEN A LONG WORK IN PROGRESS.
AND SO I APPRECIATE YOUR HARD
WORK ALWAYS -- AND WITHOUT WHICH
LIKE CLOSE EVEN CHAIR AGAIN THE
INDIVIDUALS HERE WITH ME
REPRESENT ALL THE HARD WORK
ALONG WITH MR NOW FROM THE
COMMITTEE THIS CANNOT SAY THANK
YOU ENOUGH.
I TO BE A TO COME TO CONSENSUS
ON THIS ISSUE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THE MOST PERFECT
TIME MANAGER IT'S GREAT FOR THE
WORK WITH THE PROGRAM TIME
HOPEFULLY IS NOW CAN WE THEN.
THAT IN COURT YET THIS EVENING
AND QUICKLY.
STATUS QUORUM THIS ISLAND WE
CALL THE ROLL.
BURKE I HEAR [inaudible]
ROSE HERE [inaudible]
CHU GRAY [inaudible]
MAYES.
MELINDA.
MULLIN [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
QUIRK HERE [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
TING.
WE HAVE WE HAVE A CAR WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
WITH HIGHLY CHOLERA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRO OUR ISSUE [inaudible]
GRAY.
GRAY NOT VOTING MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELINDA'S MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I QUIRK.
I WORK I AM MCCARTY TING.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
GRAY AND ADDING NOT LOADING TO I
BANKING.
THANK YOU MANAGER.
SURE -- IN HERE THEY WE CAN ALSO
DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE'RE GONNA LET'S START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
SECOND.
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
I CAN THANK CALENDAR IS SB.
SEVEN NINETY MISS HAVE ONLY CALL
THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR BURKE BY
BURKE ON APRIL.
WELL I CHU GRAY.
GRAY I MAYES.
MAYES I'M MELINDA'S SMOLAN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE AYE QUIRK AYE
BURKE AYE MCCARTY TEAM.
THAT THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
FILE ITEM ONE SB.
FORTY THREE MISS HIGHLY CALL THE
ROLL OKAY WE NEED A MOTION A
SECOND SORRY.
FILE ITEM ONE SB FORTY THREE WE
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
FILE ITEM ONE SB.
FORTY THREE I THINK ALL EVENING
[inaudible]
DEMOCRATS
YEAH [inaudible]
YOUR DESCRIPTION DESCRIPTION.
WELL I KNOW THAT.
THIS WILL BE [inaudible]
RIGHT SHE ALRIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO A DIFFERENT ITEM LIVING
A FILE ITEM.
OKAY MOVING FILE ITEM TO SB.
THREE FORTY FOUR IN A MOTION AND
A SECOND MOVE THE BILL. FOR A
FILE ITEM TO SB.
THREE FORTY FOUR HELLER KILLING
ME TODAY.
FILE ITEM TO SB.
THREE FORTY FOUR THE CURRENT
MATH OKAY I'LL MAKE A CRAZY
SECOND.
WITH HIGHLY WE CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE AYE BRO.
BROWN NOT VOTING CHU GRAY.
GRAY NOT GRAY I MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
NOR IS AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE.
MCCARTY TING.
I THAT BILLS ON CALLED LIVE.
LIVE NEEDS ONE MOVING A FILE
ITEM. FOR SB.
FIVE THIRTY ONE HANNAH MOTION
AND A SECOND [inaudible] SEVEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND WAS HIGHLY
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BURKE HI
BURKE ON A BRO [inaudible]
BRUNO CHU GRAY.
GRAY NOT VOTING MAYES.
MAYES ONLINE MELINDA'S MOLEN.
ONE I PETRIE-NORRIS.
TRAINERS ARE QUIRK I WORK I
MCCARTY TING.
SO CALLED THAT BILLS ON COLONIES
WELL GREAT GREAT [inaudible]
AS GRAY NOT VOTING TO ONLINE NOT
BURNING TIME.
THAT BILLS OUT.
WE'RE PULLING FILE ITEM SEVEN
FROM THE AGENDA SB.
THREE FIFTEEN AND WILL MOVE TO
THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS MOVING A
FILE ITEM.
EIGHT SB.
THIRTY FOUR MOVE THE BILL I HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THIS SILENT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LISTEN IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI.
ARI BRO.
REAL ARCH TO GRAY.
GREAT ARMIES.
MAYES ARE I AM A WINDOWS SMOLAN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS ARTWORK I REACHING
THAT BILL.
THAT THAT BILL IS OUT MOVING A
FILE ITEM NINE SB SIXTY THREE
WITH HIGHLY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AYE BRO.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION IN MOTION
AND MOVED.
I KNOW THE ANSWER QUIRK.
AND MR BROUGHT.
BURKE ALL RIGHT BURKE AYE BROIL.
GRILL ON EACH TO GRAY.
I MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELINDA'S MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I QUIRK HI.
BURKE I MCCARTY TING.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TEN SB.
ONE NINETY SIX SECOND WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND TIME AND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE ON
A BRO.
BRO I TO GRAY.
GRAY I MAYES.
I'M LINDA THIS MULLIN.
WILL AND I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS OUR QUIRK HI RICK
I'M MCCARTY CHIANG THE BILL IS.
THAT BILLS OUT.
MOON FILE ELEVEN SB.
TWO FORTY EIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION
[inaudible]
A SECOND.
WITH HOME PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE I
WELL.
GROW ON EACH YOU [inaudible]
GRAY.
GRAY I MAYES.
MAYES ONLINE MELINDA'S SMOLAN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I QUIRK.
NO WORK NO MCCARTY KING. SIX
BILLS PASSED THAT BILL IS OUT
FOR MOVING FILE ITEM TWELVE SB
TWO NINETY FOUR I NEED A MOTION
AND A SECOND SECOND HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MISSILE IN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRO ARE YOU.
TO GRAY.
GRAY NOT VOTING.
MEANS.
MS AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE PETRIE-NORRIS --
TRAYNOR'S AYE QUIRK [inaudible]
NO.
QUIRK NOW WAIT A SECOND THIS IS
THE HEALTH BILL YES I SORRY.
QUIRK NO TO WORK BY WORK I WORK
SORRY.
I LOST TRACK.
RIVAS NO MCCARTY TING OR TING I
THE BILL SO THAT BILL IS OUT.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTEEN SB
THIRTY NINE THREE FORTY NINE
SORRY.
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
SECOND I WAS SECOND WAS HOME
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRO ON A TO GRAY.
GRAY I MAYES.
MS I'M MELINDA THIS MULLIN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I QUIRK NO QUIRK
NO MCCARTY TANG [inaudible]
TING.
THE BILL.
STUB BILLS OUT FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN SB FOUR TWENTY TWO A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU MS HIGHLAND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRO ALL RIGHT SHOE [inaudible]
GRAY.
GRAY I MEANS.
MAYES ARE AYE MELINDA'S MULLIN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
IN OURS I QUIRK NO QUIRK NO.
MCCARTY TING.
TING I HAVE BILLS PASSED THAT
BILL IS OUT MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AS BEFORE FIFTY ONE
MOVED SECOND WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND ASYLUM PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRO I CHU.
GRAY.
GRAY I'M MAYES.
MAYES I'M MELINDA'S.
MULLIN.
MOON ON A PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I QUIRK HI QUIRK
I'M MCCARTY KING. FOR THE FLOOR
YES THAT BILLS PASSED THAT BILL
IS OUT MOVING VIOLENCE SIXTEEN
SB.
FIVE TWENTY ONE WE HAVE A MOTION.
SECOND AND THE SECOND WITH
HIGHLAND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRO I TO GRAY.
GRAY I MAYES.
MAYES I'M MELINDA SMOLAN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS OUR AYE QUIRK HI
WORK ON A MCCARTY TING.
TING NOT VOTING.
BILL IS OUT FABULOUS OUT FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN SB.
SIX TWENTY SIX SECOND MOTION AND
A SECOND.
WITH ALLEN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE I
PEARL.
BRO I TO GRAY.
GRAY I'M MAYES.
MS ARM MELINDA'S MULLIN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS HI QUIRK.
BURKE ONLINE MCCARTY CHIANG.
TING I THAT BILLS PASSED THAT
BILL IS OUT WE NEED TO FILE ITEM.
EIGHTEEN SEVEN SB [inaudible]
SEVEN SIXTY THREE SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MISSILE IN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE I
BRAILLE.
I TO GRAY.
GRAY ARMIES.
MS I'M MELINDA THIS MULLIN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I QUIRK.
WORK I MCCARTY TING.
TING THE BILL HAS PASSED THAT
BILLS OUT FILE ITEM NINETEEN SB.
SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE AND THE
MOTION SECOND AND THE SECOND IS
SILENT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO BE YEAH YOU
SAID YOU DIDN'T SAY SEVEN FIFTY
FIVE YOU SAID SOMETHING ELSE IF
I DID I'D SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE YOU
SAID -- MAYBE I HAVE IT RIGHT.
SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE YEAH THAT
RIGHT MY RIGHT TO ROCK OKAY IT'S
SB SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE RUBIO --
IS SILENT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE AYE
BURKE AYE BRO.
BRO I TO GRAY.
GRAY I MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELINDA'S MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE MCCARTY TING.
TING I THAT BILL IS OUT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
MOVING A FILE ITEM THREE AS
BEFORE.
SIXTY EIGHT SENATOR JACKSON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
IF YOU GO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS A MEASURE
THAT I THINK REALLY DOES.
ENCAPSULATE WHAT GOOD GOVERNMENT
IS SUPPOSED. TO TO CONSIDER THIS
IS A MEASURE THAT'S GOING TO
HELP US UPDATED IMPROVE OUR
SYSTEM OF TAX CREDITS TAX
DEDUCTIONS.
AND TAX EXEMPTIONS TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE MAKING THE BEST USE OF
LIMITED PUBLIC DOLLARS.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE UP FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS BILL AND I WILL
BE TAKING AS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS.
THOSE ITEMS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS WHICH REMOVED THE LA
ALL -- AS THE RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION PERFORMING THE
ANALYSIS -- AND REPLACING IT
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHERE I THINK THERE ARE WE WILL
SEE A FAR LESS POTENTIALLY
POLITICIZED FOR MORE OBJECTIVE
ACADEMIC YOUR VIEW ALL OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE ARE?
LOOKING TO ADDRESS AND THE BILL
ALSO SUNSETS THIS -- COMMITTEE A
RATHER THE THE THE ENTITY THAT'S
GOING TO BE DOING THE ANALYSIS
SIX MONTHS AFTERWARDS SO WE WILL
NOT BE A PERMANENT ENTITY.
IT MAY AT SOME FUTURE TIME BRADY.
BE RECONSTITUTED IF WE DECIDE.
TO LOOK FURTHER ADD OTHER.
OF THESE TAX.
EXPENDITURES -- BUT THIS WILL
SUNSET IN THE BOARD ITSELF WILL --
TERMINATE AFTER THE WORK OF
ANALYZING THE TAX EXPENDITURES
AND THEN REPORTING TO THE
LEGISLATURE IS COMPLETED -- AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THAT WERE
CLARIFYING SO TO CERTAIN
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENT.
AND THE GOAL HERE IS TO GET AN
OBJECTIVE VIEW OF WHETHER OR NOT
THESE TAX EXPENDITURES THAT WE
PUT INTO PLACE.
ANYWHERE UP TO FIFTY SIXTY YEARS
AGO ARE STILL RELEVANT -- NOW
STARTING IN TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
BEYOND WE ACTUALLY ARE DOING
THAT WITH ALL OF THE NEW OR TAX
EXPENDITURES BUT THE OLD ONES
THEY'RE STILL THERE THEY'VE
NEVER BEEN EVALUATED THEY'VE
NEVER BEEN ANALYZED AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE.
FUNCTIONING AS THEY WERE
INTENDED AND WHETHER OR NOT
THERE BUT STILL BENEFITING THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
PARTICULARLY THE TAXPAYER.
SO WE NOW HAVE ABOUT EIGHTY OF
THESE TAX EXPENDITURES THERE
PROVISIONS IN THE TAX CODE EYES
I MENTION WITH CREDITS
DEDUCTIONS SALES TAX EXEMPTIONS
INCOME EXCLUSIONS.
THAT REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TAX
COLLECTED IN EXCHANGE FOR WHAT
IS AN INTENDED PUBLIC POLICY
OBJECTIVE.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS COMMISSION
THIS OUR RESEARCH ORGANIZATION
IS GOING TO DO THEY'RE GOING TO
LOOK WHAT WAS THE DESIGN PURPOSE
HASN'T MET THAT PURPOSE IS IT
STILL MEETING THEIR PURPOSE.
AND THEN IT'S GOING TO BRING
THAT DATA BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN FACT TO THE BOTH
THE ASSEMBLY GEO COMMITTEE.
AND THEN THE SENATE GEO
COMMITTEE -- TO HOLD A JOINT
PUBLIC HEARINGS TO CONSIDER THE
UC'S REPORT AND THE BOARD'S
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN --
EXCUSE ME -- I MISSED A STEP
BECAUSE THIS IS DONE IN SORT OF
TRANCHES SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
THIS AS OBJECTIVE.
AND A NON PARTISAN AS POSSIBLE
SO AFTER THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA DOES ITS RESEARCH --
IT WILL PRESENT ITS FINDINGS TO
A NON PARTISAN BOARD COMPRISED
OF THE STATE COMPTROLLER THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S THE STATE
AUDITOR AND THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE OR THEIR DESIGNEES.
ANNA REPRESENTATIVE WITH THE
STATE TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION
WHAT THEY WILL DO IS SELL
CONSIDER THIS INFORMATION AND
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE -- AS TO WHETHER THE
TAX EXPENDITURE ISSUE IS MEETING
THE PURPOSES FOR WHICH IT WAS
ESTABLISHED OR WHETHER OR NOT IT
SHOULD BE ALTERED CONTINUED OR
REPEALED.
THEN THE THAT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WILL COME BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR JOINT
HEARINGS BETWEEN THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE IN THIS COMMITTEE. TWO
AT WITH PUBLIC INPUT. TO
CONSIDER THE UC'S REPORT AND THE
BOARD'S RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN
AGAIN THAT BOARD WE'LL SUNSET
SIX MONTHS THEREAFTER SO.
THE GOAL HERE IS TO GET THE
INFORMATION WE NEED TO EVALUATE
THESE PAST EXPENDITURES BECAUSE
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT FOR
EVERY DOLLAR THAT THE STATE
THAT IT COULD GET. FORTY CENTS
OF THAT DOLLAR WOULD GO TO
EDUCATION AND THE OTHER 60%
COULD GO TO OTHER PROGRAMS NOW
IF THESE FUNDS IF THESE PROGRAMS
ARE WORKING OBVIOUSLY THE
LEGISLATURE SAY WE'RE GONNA KEEP.
BUT BECAUSE WE HAVE NO MECHANISM
IN PLACE NOW TO ADDRESS THESE
PAST TAX EXPENDITURES WE HAVEN'T
GOT A CLUE.
THIS IS SOMETHING I ACTUALLY
THAT CAME TO MY ATTENTION WHEN I
FIRST GOT ELECTED A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO INTO THE ASSEMBLY AND
WONDERED WHY WE HADN'T DONE THIS.
AND SO I'M REALLY EXCITED THAT
HERE WE ARE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY.
WITH YOUR MEMBERS WITH THE CHAIR
AND I THINK WE'VE GOT THAT SWEET
SPOT HERE THE GOAL IS NOT TO
HAVE ANY BIAS GOING IN IT JUST
ASK THE QUESTION IS IS WORKING.
DO WE WANT TO CONTINUE WITH IT
AND THEN MAKE THE DECISIONS
GOING FORWARD SO I HAVE WITH ME
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND SERRA ABACHA'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS AND WITH THAT
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY HOPE FOR A
A MOTION AND A SECOND AND THE
APPROVAL OF THIS COMMITTEE WITH
YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION CTA'S PLEASED TO BE
A CO SPONSOR OF SB FORTY EIGHT
WAYS POR SIXTY EIGHT WHICH
PROVIDES A DEEPER LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY INTO THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST EXPENSIVE TAX CREDIT AND
EXEMPTIONS.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT TO BELIEVE THAT THIS
BOARD WOULD BE A MONUMENTAL STEP
IN OBJECTIVITY AND TRANSPARENT
EVALUATION WHICH CALIFORNIA
NEEDS AND HOW WE'RE LOOKING AT
THESE ISSUES.
THE TOTAL CUMULATIVE COSTS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
THESE ITEMS INCLUDED IN MEASURE
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS ASSIST
SIXTY SIX POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS.
IRONICALLY THIS IS AT THE SAME
TIME THAT CALIFORNIA WAS IN THE
MIDST OF THE GREAT RECESSION SO
SOME MAY ASK.
WHY ARE YOU SO INTERESTED IN HOW
CALIFORNIA IS SPENDING TAX
CREDITS FOR CTA WELL I'LL TELL
YOU?
DURING THE SAME DECADE
CALIFORNIA WAS SPENDING TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS SOLELY ON
THE MOST EXPENSIVE TAX CREDITS
AND EXEMPTIONS CALIFORNIA CUT
SIXTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FROM
ITS PUBLIC SCHOOLS LEADING TO
DECIMATING CUTS FOR STUDENTS.
AND AS A SENATOR NOTED FOR EVERY
ONE DOLLAR OF A TAX CREDIT FORTY
CENTS ON THE DOLLAR IS MONEY
THAT WOULD HAVE GONE TO FUND OUR
SCHOOLS.
SO WHAT WE WANNA KNOW IS WHERE
IS ALL OF MONEY GOING IF
CALIFORNIANS SPENDING BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ON INCENTIVES THING
CALIFORNIA SHOULD KNOW WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S GETTING ITS RETURN
ON INVESTMENT.
IN ADDITIONALLY IT'S NOT ENOUGH
IN THE STATE IS TO SIMPLY SAY
WERE CREATING JOBS HOW DO WE
SPECIFICALLY NO THOSE JOBS
REALLY EXIST WHO'S GETTING THEM
ARE THEY PART TIME JOBS ARE THEY
FULL TIME JOBS.
WERE THESE TEMPORARY JOBS THAT
NO LONGER EXIST ARE THE
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE GETTING THE
JOBS COMING NOW OF ELIMINATING
ECONOMIC OCT OPPORTUNITIES FROM
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT THESE
TAX CREDITS AND EXEMPTIONS COST
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS OVER
THE PAST DECADE -- TWENTY SIX
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS SO
IMAGINE THE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES A LONG TERM
ECONOMIC OUTPUT THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN CREATED.
SHOULD THOSE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
INVESTED IN SCHOOLS WHICH THE
NATIONAL EDUCATION ASSOCIATION A
SYNDICATED COULD BE A MORE
LUCRATIVE ECONOMIC INVESTMENT.
NOW THAT SAID WE'RE NOT
ADVOCATING FOR THE ELIMINATION
OF THESE ITEMS BUT WHAT WE WANT
TO DO IS HIGHLIGHT THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF THESE TAX DECISIONS SO
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS ABLE TO
HAVE A HIGHER LEVEL OF
DISCUSSION.
OF THE TRADE OFFS THAT ARE IN
HEARING IN THE SYSTEM THAT HAS
BEEN CREATED FROM PAST
LEGISLATURE'S.
THESE ECONOMIC DECISIONS OF THE
PAST NEED TO BE EVALUATED ON
THEIR LONG TERM MERIT SO THAT
YOU CAN ASSURE THAT ALL OF THE
ECONOMIC POLICIES OF THIS
LEGISLATURE MATCH CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT VALUES.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SERRA BOTCHES
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
FOUR SIXTY EIGHT DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION PUBLIC EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE DRASTIC BUDGET
REDUCTIONS WITHOUT ANY
RECONSIDERATION OF ONGOING TAX
EXPENDITURES TO PROVIDE THE
STATE WITH FISCAL RELIEF.
SB FOUR SIXTY EIGHT ESTABLISHES
A PATH FORWARD TO INSURERS
CALIFORNIA HAS A SYSTEM TO
EVALUATE TAX EXPENDITURES
REVIEWING THEIR ECONOMIC
CONTRIBUTIONS TO ENSURE PUBLIC
FUNDS ARE SPENT WISELY.
WE APPRECIATE SENATOR JACKSON'S
RECOGNITION THAT PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT WHICH FUNDS
EDUCATION WASHED OVER THIRTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT IN THE PAST DECADE
DUE TO THE RE DIRECTION OF FUNDS
TO TAX EXPENDITURES.
PLEASE SUPPORT ESTABLISHING A
SUNSET PROCESS TO ENSURE OUR
STUDENTS AND OUR EDUCATORS ARE
NOT NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY
CONTINUING TO MAINTAIN
EXEMPTIONS THAT MAY NO LONGER
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR STATE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT HIS NAME AN
AFFILIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARC THOUGHT
ABOUT IT AND WE HAVE THE
CESSATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ACCENTS FROM
SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
SUPPORT.
STEVEN WEBER BEHALF AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES WERE MEMBERS
OF THE TERRAIN IN SUPPORT.
MOLLY BY ENEMY W. APPS ME THIRTY
NINE THIRTY HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT SINCE WE RIGHT --
RECOGNIZE THAT WE REPRESENT A
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND I JUST AS
WORKERS AND IT'S A PUBLICLY
FUNDED PROGRAM WE ARE STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF INDEPENDENT REVIEW
OF TAX MANAGERS TO MAKE SURE.
THEY'RE BENEFITING PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRIED ASSISTING
US ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETIRED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
THE COALITION FOR ADEQUATE
SCHOOL HOUSING AND SUPPORT.
THE SONG OR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEVERAL OF THE COMPANY TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT -- PARK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RYBACK LANEY OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT AND ALSO ON THE BEHALF
OF THE HILL DANCE A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRISTEN BROWN A
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT THANKS.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
CHRIS.
MANAGER CHRIS FOR KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
THE FIRST THING I WANTED TO
NOTICE -- THERE'S A LARGE
COALITION ORGANIZED BY.
THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION WHO UNFORTUNATELY
COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY WE ARE
LISTED IN OPPOSITION BUT I WOULD.
NOTICE CENTER JACKSON KNOWS THAT
THE COALITION IS OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED -- WE HAD RAISED
CONCERNS REGARDING THE
BUREAUCRACY THAT.
IS BEING CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATION AS WELL AS ENSURING
THAT THERE ARE ADEQUATE --
EVALUATION METRICS -- WHEN THE
BOARD AND IN THIS CASE THE UC
EVALUATES THESE A HANDFUL OF
BUSINESS TAX EXPENDITURE
PROGRAMS?
THAT WE DID RECEIVE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE THE AUTHOR
ACCEPTED TODAY IN COMMITTEE
EARLIER THEY'RE STILL UNDER
EVALUATION THEY'RE CERTAINLY
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF -- MADAM CHAIR AS WELL AS
THE SENATOR AND HER STAFF.
AND SO AS SOON AS WE GET A FOR
WE WILL -- GET BACK TO THE
AUTHOR IN YOUR COMMITTEE I JUST
WANT TO NOTE THE TWO QUICK ITEMS
OR THREE ON THE AMENDMENTS JUST
UPON MY OWN EVALUATION.
THE AUTHOR DID INDICATE THERE IS
A TECHNICAL AMENDMENT REGARDING
ONE OF THE SUNSET DATES.
AND ALSO IN PROPOSED SECTION
FORTY THREE CE -- THERE'S SOME
LANGUAGE ABOUT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- PROVIDING RELEVANT
TAX PAYER DATA TO THE UC -- I
THINK WE'D RATHER SEE SOME
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE ABOUT
COMPLIANCE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
REVAN TAX CODE.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PROVISIONS
OF THE REVENUE TAX CODE TO
ENSURE TAX PAYER CONFIDENTIALITY
AND WE WOULD CERTAINLY WANT ANY
TAXPAYER.
A SPECIFIC DATA AGGREGATE
OBVIOUSLY IS DIFFERENT BUT THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS REFERENCE --
TAXPAYER DATA SO WITH THAT WE
ARE STILL TECHNICALLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED BUT APPRECIATE
ALL THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE
AUTHORS TAKE IN YOUR AND YOUR
COMMITTEES WORKED ON THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR NOTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MEMBERS SERRA BUT WITH
CAL CHAMBER JUST ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF OUR COLLEAGUE MR
MCHALE LEAD PRECIADO MOMENTS A
GREAT DEAL AND RESTORE VIEW IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MEASURE IN THREE MILLION ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ALL ROCK OR
A CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
SOCIAIS XIN WE ECHO.
CAL TAX OF OUR INDUSTRY
MEASURING THE LONG TERM BENEFITS
SOME THESE TAX CREDITS IS
CHALLENGING SO WE JUST URGE THE
COMMISSION TO LOOK INTO -- A LOT
OF DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT GO
INTO THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ELLIS TO HELP YOU WITH
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE FOR THE
REASONS STATED BEFORE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOWING HE CHECK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA FRESH REDUCES SEASON
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WESTERN AYE
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION AMERICAN
PISTACHIO GROWERS.
FAR WEST EQUIPMENT DEALERS IN
WESTERN PLAN HEALTH ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DUSTIN
WHETHER BE THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION I FIRST
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THE BILL -- AS AS WAS STATED
EARLIER THE AMENDMENTS ARE JUST
IMPRINT EARLIER TODAY AND WE
WILL REVIEW OUR POSITION THEN.
SO LIKE THE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM DIMITRI WITH.
TECH NAY IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
LAUREN HIGGINS REPRESENTING BY A
CALM AND ADMIT THE ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
OPPOSING LESSON AND COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE --
AT MISTER GRAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
CENTER I FOUND MYSELF -- TORY ON
THE BILL -- ON ONE HAND I
APPRECIATE THE THE PREMISE OR
THE THE EFFORT.
TO PUT.
SUNSET DATES -- INTER RIGHT FOR
PUZZLE SO THE LEGISLATURE
REGULAR REVIEWS WHICH I THINK IS
ABSOLUTE GOOD HABITS.
FRANKLY WE OUGHT TO PUT A LOT
MORE SUNSET DATES -- IN A LOT
MORE BILLS -- HAVING SAID THAT.
THE THE NOTION OF OBJECTIVITY I
FIND A LITTLE ABSURD.
AND I THINK IF YOU TAKE A VIEW
POINT OF THE LAST FORTY YEARS --
OF THE LEGISLATURE.
ALONG WITH THE USHERING OF TERM
LIMITS WE USHERED IN A LOT OF
INDEPENDENT OBJECTIVE OBJECTIVE --
COMMISSIONS AND ENTITIES AND
AGENCIES.
AND AND THEN WE ARE SHOULD A
BUNCH OF WHAT WE ARE SHOULD OUT
ALL INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY WERE
POLICY EXPERTISE WE ARE SHOULD
IN A BUNCH OF LEGISLATURES WHO
FOR MANY YEARS WERE HERE FOR TWO
OR THREE YEARS.
AND WHO WERE HAPPY -- TO SEAT
ANY AUTHORITY OR RESPONSIBILITY
TO A MUCH UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS
WHO FRANKLY HAVE DONE FOR THE
MOST PART A TERRIBLE JOB.
NOW SOME OF YOU -- AND SOME OF
THE FOLKS IN OUR BODY MAY
APPRECIATE THAT TERRIBLE JOB
THEY'VE DONE BECAUSE IT MIXES
WITH THEIR IDEOLOGICAL -- YOU
KNOW BENT OR VIEW POINT -- BUT
DOESN'T SERVE CALIFORNIANS WELL
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY WHEN
YOU COME AND SAY OKAY WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A REVIEW BOARD.
THAT HAS THE CONTROLLER OR
CONTROLLER DOESN'T ME THE LA --
THE STATE AUDITOR.
THESE ARE NOT INDEPENDENT
OBJECTIVE PEOPLE THESE ARE THE
CONTROLLERS ELECTED AND THEIR
POINTY IS GOING TO BE --
CONSISTENT WITH THEIR
PERSPECTIVE THERE'S NOT REALLY
SUCH THING AS AN OBJECTIVE.
POINT OF VIEW.
IF THERE WERE WE WOULDN'T SEE
EFFORTS SOME IN SOME OF THE BEST.
EXPENDITURES FOR EXAMPLE OF G.
G. R. F. MONEY.
IT OUR BATTLE AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE HAVE BEEN IN THE AREA --
THERE IS I REPRESENT RIGHT WE
DIDN'T ALICE'S SOME YEARS AGO
AND USE YOUR OF MONEY AND FOUND
OUT THAT.
YOU KNOW FOR FIFTY OR SIXTY
DOLLARS -- AT A METRIC TON -- WE
WERE GETTING THE BEST VALUE IN
CARBON REDUCTION IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BUT WAS MOST THE MONEY
SPENT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY APPS
WE NOT.
YOU KNOW SPEND A FIVE SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS METRIC TON IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE BAY
AREA -- YEAH WHEN IT COMES TIME
TO EXPAND A CREDIT FOR EXAMPLE
FOR PRODUCTION COMPANIES NOW LAY
THERE'S ALL THE OVERWHELMING
VOTES FOR IT WHEN IT COMES -- TO
DO TAX CREDITS FOR RURAL
COMMUNITIES THERE'S NOT RIGHT SO
I WOULD SUGGEST THERE'S VERY
LITTLE OBJECTIVITY ANY THIS
THERE'S POLITICS AS USUAL -- AND
I WOULD PREFER TO KEEP MY
POLITICS AS USUAL RIGHT HERE AT
THE LEGISLATURE WHERE WE'RE ALL
ACCOUNTABLE WHETHER IT'S MR
QUIRK IN HIS DISTRICT OR ADAM
GRAY IN HIS WE HAVE TO GO BACK
TO THE VOTERS AND EXPLAIN OUR
POSITIONS -- AND IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO VET THESE TAX
PROPOSALS NOT TO KICK IT.
TO SOME ALLEGEDLY OBJECTIVE
BOARD THIS GONNA GIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS BACK TO US -- SO
FRANKLY I WOULD KIND OF SAY TO
OURSELVES LET'S JUST DO OUR JOB --
NOT CREATE MORE UNACCOUNTABLE
UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS -- BUT
HAVING SAID THAT I LIKE THE
INTENT OF WHERE YOU'RE GOING --
I THINK I'M GONNA LAY OFF.
TODAY BUT WOULD WELCOME AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION ON THE
SUBJECT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE RAISING I MEAN
TAX MANAGERS OUR PUBLIC POLICY
DECISIONS -- BUT I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO KIND OF PUT TO BED THIS
NOTION THAT THERE'S THESE
OBJECTIVES THAT YOU KNOW WE
DON'T NEED DEMOCRACY BECAUSE WE
CAN JUST FIND OBJECTIVE
BUREAUCRATS TO MAKE OUR
DECISIONS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOOD
GOVERNMENT AND I DON'T WANT TO
SUPPORT MEASURES THAT -- THAT
LEND THEMSELVES TO THAT TYPE OF
THINKING.
SIR IF I MAY RESPOND THAT'S WHY
THIS IS THREE THE CARD THREE
LEVELS THE FIRST LEVEL IS
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WE RELY
UPON THEM FOR A LOT OF THE
RESEARCH THAT WE HAVE IN THE
STATE.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN GIVEN.
SPECIFIC MANDATE TO LOOK AT
THESE AND TO CONSIDER A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT FACTORS -- AND THAT
IS THEIR JOB IS TO COME UP WITH
THE DATA.
THE SECOND IS TO TAKE THAT DATA
AND TO BRING.
TO BRING FORWARD A SO THAT'S OF
THAT'S THE FIRST LEVEL IS THE
FACT FINDER.
THE SECOND LEVEL IS -- ELECTED
OFFICIALS -- WHOSE EXPERTISE IS
SUPPOSED TO BE IN MONEY.
IF YOU WILL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CONTROLLER AND THE OTHER
OF THE VARIOUS DIFFERENT FOLKS.
THEY WILL THEN COME WITH THE
REPORT THAT WILL COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY WE ARE
THE LEGISLATURE IS ACCOUNTABLE
BECAUSE WE WILL TAKE THAT
INFORMATION AND THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS -- GATHER THE
EXPERTS IN IN TAX AROUND FROM
BOTH.
THE ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE HAVE
PUBLIC HEARING SO WE CAN GET THE
INPUT OF ALL THE DIFFERENT
GROUPS AND THEN IT WILL BE UP TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO DECIDE WHAT
TO DO -- WITH ALL THE
INFORMATION AND THE
DETERMINATIONS AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND EITHER APPLY
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OR NOT.
AND I SHARE WITH YOU I REPRESENT
THE CENTRAL COAST WE'RE NOT VERY
WELL LISTEN TO EITHER VERY MUCH
THE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SENATE SEEMS TO SOMETIMES SKIP
OVER US.
TOO SO I AND I APPRECIATE THE
THE FRUSTRATION BUT WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS ESSENTIALLY PULL
BACK THE CURTAINS AND CREATE
SUNSHINE FOR PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE NEVER EVALUATED.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT IT THAT WAY I
THINK IT ADDRESSES THE CONCERNS
YOU HAVE AND I SHARE YOUR
FRUSTRATION BUT I I DON'T THINK
THAT'S QUITE WHAT WE'VE GOT HERE
IN THIS BILL -- DOCTOR PARK AND
THEN MR MAYES.
SO -- I'M HOPING I CAN BIG
MISTER GRAY OVER TO A NIGHT BUT
WE'LL SEE -- WITHOUT DATA WE ARE
FLYING BLIND.
NOW I LOVE THE R. D. TAX CREDIT.
I THINK IT'S WONDERFUL BUT I
DON'T KNOW.
YOU KNOW IF WE LOSE INDUSTRIES
IF WE DIDN'T HAVE IT -- YOU KNOW
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN -- AND I I
DON'T KNOW THAT I'LL LOOK
TERRIBLY CLOSELY AT WHAT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SAYS
BUT I'M SURE AS HECK AND LOOK
VERY CLOSELY AT NUMBERS.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU SEE WILL
PRESENT.
SO ARE WE ARE FLYING BLIND
WITHOUT IT NOW I REALLY.
I FIND IT HARD TO BELIEVE I
WOULDN'T SUPPORT THE ARE ANTI
TAX CREDIT BUT LET'S SEE WHAT
THE DATA SAYS ARM.
ANYWAY -- I'D LIKE TO THIS POINT
MOVE THE BELL.
ALL RIGHT AND THEN -- IF YOU
COULD IF YOU DO AMEND THE BILL
AGAIN I'D LOVE TO BE A CO AUTHOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THIS A ACTUALLY BUT MISTER GRAY
MOVE ME ON THIS ONE I WAS --
ACTUALLY GOING TO SUPPORT THIS --
TODAY AND I THINK I'M YEAH I
THINK I'M ACTUALLY GOING TO LAY
OFF AND I'LL TELL YOU WHY --
YOUR INTENT IS RIGHT -- I THINK
WE SHOULD KNOW -- YOU KNOW.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH AS A
REPUBLICAN I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF
TAX CREDITS -- BUT I VOTE FOR
THEM OFTEN DUMB AND I'M NOT A
BIG FAN OF TAX CREDITS BECAUSE I
THINK OUR TAX RATE IS TOO HIGH --
I'M SOMEBODY IS SAID IN FACT I
HEAR ALL THE TIME HERE IN THIS
BUILDING THAT WE SHOULD BE
PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS AND
YET GUESS WHAT WE DO -- WE PICK
WINNERS AND LOSERS.
AND I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR THIS LEGISLATURE GOT TO BE
RESPONSIBLE TO ACTUALLY OUR JOB
AND THAT'S WHERE MISTER GRAY GOT
ME IS ACTUALLY OUR JOB TO DO
THAT THE REASON I JUST I WANT TO
BE ON THE REVENUE TAX COMMITTEE.
WAS BECAUSE I HEARD BACK IN
DECEMBER THAT WE WERE THAT
THERE'S A POSSIBILITY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTED TO DO
COMPREHENSIVE TAX REFORM AND I
WANTED TO BE A PART.
OF THAT OF THAT CONVERSATION
BECAUSE OF MY BACKGROUND IT IS
OUR JOB TO DO THAT.
IN ADDITION TO NOT JUST GOING IN
STUDYING AND UNDERSTANDING --
WHETHER WE HAVE TOO MANY
CORPORATE LOOPHOLES -- BUT
THERE'S ALSO THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER WE SPEND TOO MUCH MONEY
AND PROGRAMS WHETHER THERE'S AN
EFFICACY WITH THE DOLLARS THAT
WE SPENT I'M SO I THINK PARTLY
THIS IS A BIT INCOMPLETE AS WELL.
IT IS OUR JOB AS THE LEGISLATURE
TO DO TO DO THIS WORK WE
SHOULDN'T KEEP.
YOU KNO DELEGATING THIS TO
OTHER -- COMMISSIONS IN KING
COUNCILS WE HAVE TOO MANY OF
THEM ALREADY AND IN LARGE PART
IT'S BECAUSE AS A BODY WE DON'T
HAVE THE COURAGE TO MAKE
DECISIONS THAT ARE THAT ARE
DIFFICULT.
AND FOR THAT REASON I'M GONNA
LAY OFF TODAY AS WELL IF I IF I
COULD JUST KEEP ASKING KEEP AN
OPEN MIND SHOP OF THE SECOND
COURSE I WILL.
THE FIRST IS THE DATA THE SECOND
IS THE ANALYSIS IF YOU WILL THE
THIRD IS IT IS COMING BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND HOPEFULLY IT
WILL BE -- INFORMATION THAT CAN
THEN BE PROPERLY ANALYZED BY
THIS COMMITTEE.
AND BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE.
IN CONJUNCTION AND HOLDING
PUBLIC HEARINGS AT WHICH POINT.
EITHER WAY.
YOU CAN CHOOSE WHEN WE CAN
CHOOSE AS A LEGISLATURE TO ACT
OR NOT ACT AND WE CAN ACT ANY%
WAY WE WANT WE'RE NOT BOUND BY
ANYTHING.
THAT IS GOING TO COME TO US
BASICALLY I SEE IT AS A WAY TO
HELP US FOCUS.
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T DONE THIS.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE THERE TAX
CREDIT SHELTER FROM THE NINETEEN
FORTIES.
WE DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES HERE
IN FACT THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WE MOVED THE RESEARCH
FROM THE LA ALL. TO THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA'S BECAUSE
WE DON'T OF THE RESEARCH
MECHANISM HERE TO DO THAT IT
RESEARCH TO FIND OUT JUST WHAT
THESE TAX CREDITS ARE AND HOW
THEY HAVE.
IMPACTED HOW THEY'VE COMPLIED OR
OR PERFORM BASED UPON THEIR
INTENDED PURPOSE SO THAT'S THE
FIRST STEP THE SECOND IS THAT
INFORMATION WILL THEN COME TO
THIS GROUP OF OF EXPERTS IF YOU
WILL WHO ARE ELECTED BUT
ARGUABLY BUREAUCRATS I GUESS YOU
COULD SAY THEY RUN.
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS WHERE
THERE IS A CERTAIN EXPERTISE AND
IT IS THEN BROUGHT TO WATCH AS A
LEGISLATURE. TO DO WITH AS WE
WISH TO DO WITH SO THERE WERE
RESPONDING TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
TO THE PRIORITIES THAT WE HAVE
IS A STATE TO THE ISSUES THAT
ARE COMING BEFORE US AT THE TIME.
I WILL TELL YOU TEN YEARS AGO WE
WEREN'T LOOKING FOR MONEY TO DO
TO ADDRESS THE HOMELESSNESS
PROBLEM BUT WE ARE TODAY.
AND WHO KNOWS WHAT IT'LL BE IN A
YEAR OR TWO OR FIVE BUT IT WILL
BE THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE. TO MAKE THOSE FINAL
DECISION SO WE'RE NOT ABROGATING
RESPONSIBILITIES TO ANYBODY ELSE
THEY ARE PROVIDING US WITH THE
INFORMATION AND RECOMMENDATIONS
WHICH WE CAN ACCEPT OR WE CAN
REJECT.
AND I AND THE IDEA THAT WE THEN
ALLOW THE PUBLIC PUBLIC COMMENT
SO THAT WE CAN GET INPUT FROM
THOSE WHO DISAGREE. FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE OTHER THOUGHTS AND
SUGGESTIONS THAT WILL COME
BEFORE THIS BODY FOR THE
ULTIMATE DETERMINATION WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT GIVING AWAY.
ANY OF OUR RESPONSIBILITIES I
BELIEVE WITH AT THE WAY THAT
WE'VE TRIED TO SET THIS UP.
ULTIMATELY THE BOTTOM LINE IS IT
WILL BE UP TO WATCHES A
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE THOSE
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY
DECISIONS.
IN THAT I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
YOU WITH ALL OF THAT I THINK
JUST THE QUESTION IS WE OFTEN
HAVE THESE DO THESE STUDIES
MAYES ARE SET ON THE SHELF AND
AND DO NOTHING THE UC CAN DO
THIS WORK THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ALREADY HAS THE
CAPACITY TO BE ABLE. TO DO SOME
OF THIS WORK AND I I FEEL AS
THOUGH THIS IS SORT OF A A PASS
FOR US THAT WE WE WE GO WELL GO
STUDY IT BUT THEN WE DON'T DO
MUCH.
ABOUT IT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
HOW MUCH WE SPEND OUR DOLLARS
AND I DON'T THINK WE WE GET THE
MOST EFFICIENT BANG FOR OUR BUCK
IN THE WAY WE SPEND MONEY.
NOR DO I THINK THAT WE ARE OUR
TAX SYSTEM -- GENERATE THE
REVENUE THAT WE NEED TO BE
COMPETITIVE IN A GLOBAL
MARKETPLACE -- SO AGAIN I THINK
THAT IT IS INCUMBENT UPON US TO
DO THAT WORK I JUST DON'T WANT
TO TO TO DISH THAT OFF TO
SOMEBODY ELSE.
I'M.
REALLY QUICKLY JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION PURPOSES WE DID
LOOK AT THE LA L. -- BECAUSE WE
DO THE COMMITTEE FELT LIKE THE
LA -- WAS PROBABLY THE BEST
PLACE SOME PLACE THAT WE ALL
TRUST THE LA -- DIDN'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY NOR DO WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO FIND THEM IN A WAY
THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM THE THE
STAFFING TO DO THIS THEY WOULD
HAVE TO DO ONE OF BECAUSE THESE
ARE SUCH LARGE INSTEAD BECAUSE
THEY'RE SO CONFERENCE IF.
THEY WOULD ONLY BE ABLE TO DO
ONE A YEAR AND THAT WE DID NOT
FEEL AS EFFICIENT WHICH IS WHY
WE MOVED IT OUT OF THE LA --
JUST SO THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THAT ELLIE -- WAS THE INITIAL --
WAS THE INITIAL CONCEPT IT THEY
JUST DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY NOR
DO WE HAVE THE FUNDING MECHANISM
IN PLACE TO ALLOW OURSELVES TO
FIND THEM TO MAKE THEM.
CAPABLE OF DOING IT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
SAID SENATOR LIKE YOU AND LIKE
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES I WOULD
SAY I THINK WE NEED TO DO A MUCH
BETTER JOB AND ENSURING THAT
WE'RE SPENDING OUR TAXPAYER
DOLLARS EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY.
SOMEONE WHO WAS NOT ELECTED A
HUNDRED YEARS AGO ACTUALLY QUITE
RECENTLY.
NOT SERRATION I'VE HAD IS YOU
KNOW WE PASS A LOT OF LINES.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PRESS
CONFERENCES AND WE DON'T ALWAYS
DO A GOOD JOB AT LOOKING BACK
AND SAYING.
IS THAT MONEY GOING WHERE IT WAS
INTENDED TO GO IS THAT MONEY
HAVING THE IMPACT IT WAS
INTENDED TO HAVE I'M SO I WOULD
I WOULD ECHO ADD ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES COMMENTS.
TERMS OF THIS ONE BEING PART OF
THE EQUATION RIGHT TO THE
SUCCESS.
AT TAX EXPENDITURES THERE'S A
WHOLE LOT OF OTHER EXPENDITURES
I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE A MUCH.
MUCH BETTER LOOK AT AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY I
ASSURE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
AROUND FIVE UNITS THE
BUREAUCRACY AND MAKE SURE THAT.
THIS ISN'T JUST SOME THE REPORT
THAT SITS ON THE SHELF BUT I
ALSO THINK THAT THE ONLY WAY
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
BETTER DECISIONS IS BY HAVING
BETTER DATA SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING.
I FEEL VERY CONFIDENT THAT THE
EDUCATION COMMUNITY.
WILL NOT LET THIS **** ON A
SHELF.
ESPECIALLY IF THERE ARE
RESOURCES THAT ARE BEING
INAPPROPRIATELY AT LEAST FROM
THEIR PERSPECTIVE SPENT AND
THERE WILL BE A VERY ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS GOING
FORWARD.
AS THERE SHOULD BE AND I AGREE
THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT AREAS
THIS IS ONE CHUNK OF A PROBLEM
BECAUSE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE INDICATES THAT.
BY TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE WILL
HAVE BEEN A FIVE HUNDRED AND SIX
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLAR LOSS
IN REVENUE TO THE GENERAL FUND
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
AND THAT'S MONEY AT GOING
FORWARD THAT UNLESS IT'S REALLY
SERVING ITS DESIGN PURPOSE AS WE
THE LEGISLATURE.
DETERMINE -- THEN IT'S MONEY
THAT IS NOT BEING A PROPERLY
SPENT TWO TO RESPOND TO THE
TAXPAYER WHICH IS OUR ONE OF OUR
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITIES AS WELL
[inaudible]
MR TANG.
THANK YOU MA'AM TRUMP'S GONNA
PICK UP ON WHERE ARE CHAIR OF
SORTS LEFT OFF I THINK THIS --
THIS TYPE OF LOOK IS LONG
OVERDUE WE DON'T WE DON'T EVER
LOOK AT TAXES WE CANNOT I I
PROBABLY HAVE THE LARGEST
COMMITTEE STAFFER BUDGET
COMMITTEE WE DON'T HAVE.
ANYBODY WHO REALLY IS THERE
FOCUSED ON JUST LOOKING AT TAX
EXPENDITURES EVEN THOUGH TWO
HUGE.
PORTION OF OUR BUDGET EVERY
SINGLE YEAR -- IN ADDITION AS A
CHAIR MENTIONED ALEJO'S NOT
STAFF WITH THIS.
AND I THINK IT IS LONG OVERDUE
THAT WE DO.
TAKE A HARD LOOK AT MONEY THAT
WE ARE APPROPRIATING EVERY
SINGLE YEAR BUT WE DON'T REALLY
APPROPRIATE DOESN'T GO THROUGH
COMMITTEE.
DOESN'T REALLY GO THROUGH A
BUDGET BILL SO JUST GIVE ME
SCRUTINY IT DOESN'T REALLY GET
THE KIND OF THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS
THAT WE NEED.
SO I I REALLY APPRECIATE -- YOU
GET TO STAB AT IT -- HI I'M I
HAVE A COUPLE -- UP YOU KNOW.
DIFFERENCES DOWN THE ROAD BUT
OVERALL I THINK THIS IS GREAT TO
ACTUALLY TAKE A HARD LOOK.
AT WHAT OUR WHAT OUR TAX DOLLARS
ARE GOING TO HOW THEY'RE BEING
SPENT.
AS AS MR PARK SAID HE IS THE
MONEY ACTUALLY GETTING THE KIND
OF RESULT.
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD IN THE
ANALYSIS ON YOU KNOW I'M I'M
LIKE MR MAYS I'M NOT A HUGE FAN
A TAX CREDITS BY FOR MYSELF
VOTING FOR YOU KNOW.
A LOT MORE THAN I'D LIKE OR THAT
I DON'T THINK I SHOULD PARTLY
BECAUSE WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GET
THE TAX CREDIT.
THERE WAS ALSO A GOOD IDEA.
WE WE ALMOST RARELY UNLESS WE
SANTA SET THEM NOW WE'VE GONE TO
A GOOD HABIT OF DOING THAT.
EVER LOOK BACK TEN YEARS LATER
HEY DID ACTUALLY WORK TO DO THE
ANALYSIS THAT SAID HE WAS GOING
TO WORK ACTUALLY PAY OFF I THINK.
THAT THIS IS ON LONG OVERDUE TO
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT I
THINK IT'S VERY FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE BECAUSE IT IS THE
LARGEST PART OF OUR BUDGET THAT
WE NEVER LOOK AT NEVER.
SO I THINK IT IS -- REALLY
PUSHING.
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT
[inaudible]
MISTER MALONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU SENATOR -- FOR BRINGING THE
BILL LIKE MR TANG I THINK --
THIS KIND OF A COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW IS OVERDUE -- IT'S
WELCOMED.
A DEEP LOOK AT THE VALUE OF
THESE TAX EXPENDITURES GIVEN
SORT OF THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
OVERALL BUDGET.
BUT LIKE MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
QUIRK FROM EAST BAY I AM A FAN
OF THE RD.
TAX CREDIT I'VE -- WE ARE
BRACING FOR FIFTEEN THOUSAND NEW
JOBS JUST IN MY HOMETOWN OF
SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO BUNCH OF IT
ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE FAVORABLE.
TAX ENVIRONMENT IN CALIFORNIA
FOR THESE KINDS OF JOBS BUT I
MYSELF HAVE NOT DONE IT.
DEEP LOOK AT THE OVERALL VALUE
SO IT IS WORTHY TO HAVE THE TO
HAVE THE CONVERSATION.
MY EXPECTATION IS HOWEVER WHEN
THIS REPORT COMES BACK -- TO
THIS BODY AND THE AND THE
EQUIVALENT BODY OF THE SENATE
THAT WE WILL LOOK AT EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THE SITE.
IS IT YOUR EXPECTATION THAT WE
WILL HAVE HEARINGS BUT IT'S NOT
AS THOUGH WE'RE GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT AN OMNIBUS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WITH ALL OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS WRAPPED UP LIKE.
OCCASIONALLY WILL HAVE BLUE
RIBBON TASK FORCE AND SO FORTH
AND AND A OF A BIG PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT'S ALL
ENCOMPASSING MY EXPECTATION.
IS THAT WE WILL LOOK AT EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THESE LIKE WE
NORMALLY DO HI IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
TO TO EVALUATE THE REPORT --
BITE AT MY EXPECTATION IS THAT
THIS COMMITTEE IN PERFORMING ITS
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT WILL ALSO
BRING IN OTHER FOLKS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE PREVIOUS PROCESS --
BECAUSE EACH ONE OF THESE -- I
THINK ON THE MERITS -- ABROAD
REVIEW BY THIS BODY -- TO ACT AS
SOMETHING OF A CHECK FRANKLY ON
THE OUTSIDE A REPORT AND THAT'S
GENERALLY HOW THESE THINGS WORK
WITH THAT THAT'S CORRECT YEAH.
THE ONCE THAT THIS IS A WE'RE
SETTING UP A PROCESS.
AND THEN IT COMES TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE ONLY PART OF
THAT LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
IS THAT WE WE CALL FOR JOINT
HEARINGS -- FOR THE REV REVENUE
TAX.
A COMMITTEES TO GET TOGETHER AND
TO HAVE SOME PUBLIC HEARINGS
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THAT.
REALLY THERE THE BILL IS SILENT
BECAUSE I EXPECT THERE WHAT WILL
HAPPEN IN PROBABLY WHAT SHOULD
HAPPEN IS EACH ONE OF THESE WILL
BE CONSIDERED ON THEIR OWN
MERITS FOR EXAMPLE THE ARE
INDEED CREDIT.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE SO
THAT THAT SO IT'S REALLY CLEAR I
THINK WAS IN TWENTY FOURTEEN OR
AT SOME POINT WE DID A TAX
CREDIT FOR THE ENTERTAINMENT
BUSINESS.
AND WE SAIDOKAY WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE YOU THIS TAX CREDIT BUT YOU
GOTTA COME BACK IT'S GOING TO
SUNSET.
UNLESS YOU COME BACK AND SHOW US
WHY.
THIS HAS BEEN A BENEFIT TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO MAKE YOUR CASE WELL
NOT ONLY DID THEY MAKE THEIR
CASE THEY MADE THEIR CASE SO
WELL THAT WE DOUBLE THE TAX
CREDIT.
BECAUSE OF THAT WHAT WHAT WAS
ESTABLISHED TO BE THE BENEFIT UP
FOR EVERY DOLLAR THAT WE GAVE IT
A TAX CREDIT WE GOT SIX DOLLARS
BACKERS SOME NUMBER.
AND AND I THINK THAT AND NOW
WITH EVERY TAX CREDIT WE DO FROM
I THINK TWENTY FOURTEEN ON WE
REQUIRE THAT SAME PROCESS FOR
THOSE IT HAPPENED BEFORE THAT WE
HAVE NO PROCESS.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL TRIES
TO DO.
IS TO IS BASICALLY TURNED US SET
ASIDE THE CURTAIN ON THESE TAX
HAD TO GIVE ANY KIND OF
ACCOUNTING -- COMMENDATION OR
ANALYSIS SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
IT AND AND WHAT'S INTERESTING IS
THAT THE LAST THE DISNEY DID A
AN EVENT HERE LOCALLY AND WE'RE
ALL SITTING THERE WAITING FOR
THE MOVIE TO START NAY WANT TO
TELL US.
WHAT A GREAT TAX CREDIT THIS IS
THEY COULDN'T HELP THEMSELVES
BUT TO PROVIDE US WITH THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE IF THE DATA
IS THERE?
THOSE TAX CREDITS ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE [inaudible]
MISTER CURRY.
THANK YOU ARE YOU KNOW I'M I'M
AT A SUB HERE TODAY FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS BUT I'M GLAD I'M
HERE FOR THIS HEARING BECAUSE
THIS IS A BILL THAT I I HEARD.
FROM FROM -- BEFORE YOU TOOK IT
ON FROM THE PEOPLE IN THE
EDUCATION GROUP BUT I KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TAX POLICY BOWS
ONE TALK FOR A BRIEF SECOND
ABOUT.
SCHOOLS AND I HAD THE PLEASURE
OF A YEAR OF HEALTH RECONCILING
THE BUDGET FOR OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND ALWAYS SAY THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT WE'VE INCREASE
SCHOOL FUNDING IN A LAST ROUGHLY
FIVE YEARS BY 50%.
AND A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF NEW
MONEY GOING TO OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THE BAD NEWS AS WE KNOW
WE'RE STILL -- FORTY FIRST IN
THE NATION AND AND THAT THEN WHY
ARE WE HERE WHY IS IT AN ISSUE
BECAUSE OF THIS BECAUSE WE DO
SPEND A LOT TIME -- LOOKING
FORWARD BUT NOT AS MUCH TIME
LOOKING BACK AND THAT'S OUR
THAT'S INDICTMENT FRANKLY OUR
BUDGET PROCESS TO BUT ALSO THESE
THESE TAX POLICY.
ISSUES AND I I I DO I KNOW I
THINK IT WAS NOT ONLY THIS
COMMITTEE BUT I THINK OUR CENTER
LET NO IN YOUR HOUSE WOULD SET
THIS POLICY.
LOOKING GOING FORWARD LIKE THE
HOLLYWOOD TAX CREDIT.
AND YOU KNOW WE WE HAVEN'T GONE
BACK AND IT'S NOT JUST TO GOTCHA
BUT SEE WHICH ONES ARE WORKING
AND I THINK.
OUR VOTERS PROBABLY THINK THEY
WERE DOING THIS IN THE FIRST
PLACE THAT'S THE SAD TRUTH HERE
IS THEY BUY THANK.
WHAT YOU HAVEN'T GONE BACK A
LOOK TO SEE WHAT'S WORKING
WHAT'S NOT WORKING?
AND WHY IT MATTERS IS BECAUSE
YOU KNOW.
PARENTS ARE SEEING THAT THE DIP
IN THEIR POCKETS TO PAY.
FOR THE ENRICHMENT PROGRAMS AT
THEIR SCHOOL WITH MUSIC AND
SPORTS AND ARTS -- AND CERTAIN
NEIGHBORHOODS I WOULD HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY WE KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS AS WELL AND SO -- YOU KNOW
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PUBLIC
POLICY FOR GOOD GOVERNMENT IT
REALLY MATTERS TO THE FUTURE.
OF OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM AND
BECAUSE WE CAN'T KEEP LOOKING
FOR NEW TAXES WE SPY LOOK AT THE
ONES THE TAX -- TAX BREAKS WE
HAVE UNDER THE CURRENT -- YES
STATE POLICY AND SEE WHICH ONES
ARE REALLY EFFECTIVE SO I I'D I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I'M GLAD I GOT TO GO
ON THIS TODAY AND FLOOR.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
MR GREY.
WHY PROMISED YOU CENTER THAT
KEEP AN OPEN MIND I DID?
THAT I LISTENED ALTHOUGH I'M NOT
CONVINCED -- YEAH I BEGAN MY
TIME IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAIRPERSON
OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT.
COMMITTEE I KNOW YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THE MANY OF US ARE.
AND REGULARLY WE PUT IT ON IT'S
NOT THE IN AN ANNUAL BASIS THE
COMMITTEE ACTUALLY.
SENDS US A BOOKLET WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS.
I SEE YOU HAVE IT I HAVE A AND I
WOULD.
LOOK BACK AT ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO HOW MANY
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED.
THE ANSWER IS VERY FEW.
SO THE NOTION THAT WE'RE GOING
TO GET ANOTHER.
COMMITTEE OR ANOTHER SOME OTHER
FOLKS TO GET US SOME OBJECTIVE
DATA.
THAT SOMEHOW GONNA CHANGE OUR
MINDS -- IS LOOP SORT OF WE TALK
ABOUT CAPACITY RIGHT.
WITH THE LA -- DOESN'T HAVE
CAPACITY THE BUDGET CHAIRMAN.
DOESN'T HAVE CAPACITY THE REV
AND TAX COMMITTEE WHERE WE MAKE
REVENUE TAX POLICY DOES NOT OF
CAPACITY BUT THIS NEW COMMISSION
COMMITTEE OF FEW FOLKS IS GOING
TO HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO THIS
JOB THAT NONE OF US.
COLLECTIVELY -- COULD DO BEFORE
THEM THAT'S AN ABSURD NOTION --
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR HERE IS
HONESTY IN IN IN POLICY MAKING
POLITICS AND IT'S HARD TO FIND?
ON YOUR I JUST INTRODUCED A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. TO A
CALTRAIN HYDRO'S ROOM WONDERED.
NOW WE CAN GET A THOUSAND
SCIENTISTS IN THE ROOM AND THEY
WOULD ALL AGREE THAT TURNED OVER
ENERGY THAT'S NOT GOING TO
CHANGE THE WAY THIS COMMITTEE --
BOATS -- IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME
THAT TO MY COLLEGE IN THE BAY
AREA LIKE THE RD TAX CREDIT.
I'M SHOCKED -- YOUR THAT THE
THESE THINGS REQUIRE ADVOCACY
AND THE INFORMATION IS READILY
AVAILABLE NOW IN THE PUBLIC AND
THEIR OPPOSING SIDES OF
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES ON EACH
ISSUE.
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
COMMITTEES AND THE IRONY OF
SITTING IN THE REVAN TALKED TO
ME AND SAID ASSEMBLY AND SAY WE
GOT A PART.
ON THIS POLICY OF WHAT OUR TAX
EXPENDITURES ARE IS ABSURD.
SO AFTER LISTEN TO THE BAD I
LIVE CLOSE THE DOOR NO THEN --
THEN THE YES BUT I'M STILL GOING
TO ABSTAINED BECAUSE AGAIN I
THINK -- THE UNDERLYING PREMISE
THAT YOU'RE APPROACHING THIS
WITH THE SOMETHING THAT I
RESPECT AND AND AGREE WITH YOUR
INTENTIONS ON I JUST.
SIGNIFICANTLY SERIOUSLY DISAGREE
WITH THE APPROACH AS LAID OUT
THIS BILL.
WELL I APPRECIATE THAT -- WITH
PART OF THIS BILL IS BASED UPON
THE TWENTY FIFTEEN LA -- TWENTY
SIXTEEN LA -- SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THE AUDITOR
EXCUSE ME THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS SO.
I KNOW THE WHEELS OF POLICY
MOVES SLOWLY.
OUR BLOOD WE REALLY ARE AT THE
POINT WHERE WE HAVE TAKEN THAT
REPORTS SERIOUSLY AND I SERVED
ON J. LIKE FOR SIX YEARS IN THE
ASSEMBLY SO I I APPRECIATE THE
WORK IT DOES.
AT WE TAKE THIS VERY SERIOUSLY
AND WHAT WE'VE CALLED UPON IS
THE EXPERTISE.
OF NOT ONLY THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA BUT ALL OF THE
VARIOUS AGENCIES THAT WILL THEN
BE TAKING IN TRYING TO ANALYZE.
THAT INFORMATION AND SO I THINK
THAT THAT BECOMES -- THE FOCUS
AND YOU KNOW.
I DON'T SURE -- GOSH I HOPE I
DON'T SURE THAT.
THAT SENSE OF KIND OF CYNICISM
HOW HER SYSTEM WHEN I MEAN IT'S
NOT PERFECT BY ANY MEANS BUT I
DO THINK THAT -- WE AIR THIS IN
PUBLIC WE MAKE EVALUATIONS
EVERYBODY MAKES THEIR BEST CASE.
ARE AND THEN WE DECIDE AS A BODY.
WHAT TAX BREAKS WERE GONNA GIVE
WE DECIDE WHETHER WE WANT THAT
MONEY TO INSTEAD TO GO INTO
EDUCATION -- AS IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY POINTED OUT
THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY HERE
THAT'S BEEN LEFT ON THE TABLE --
AND WE IS A BODY GET TO DECIDE
WHETHER AS A POLICY THAT'S A
GOOD THING OR BAD THING SO SO I
LOOK AT THIS -- AS A LITTLE MORE
OF A PROACTIVE PROCESS BUT I
UNDERSTAND IF I KEEP TALKING I'M
GONNA GET YOU TO KNOW SO I'M NOT
GONNA SAY ANYTHING FURTHER.
SO IS THAT YOUR CLOTHES THAT'LL
BE MY CLOTHES ALL RIGHT.
THE CHAIR IS GOING TO BE -- GONE
FOR A WHILE IN THE VICE CHAIR IS
PROBABLY GOING PERMANENTLY.
SO I'M TEMPORARILY TAKING OVER
PERHAPS -- FOR THE REST OF THIS --
MEETING HERE -- HER -- SHE HAS A
TO PASS.
AS AMENDED RECOMMENDATION --
MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU READ
THE MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE GROW.
CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
YOURS ARE A QUIRK.
QUIRK ARE AYE MCCARTY AYE CURTI
AYE TING.
THE ONCOLOGY CURRENTLY JOHN CALL
IT NEEDS ONE THANK YOU NOW LIKE
TO RETURN TO ITEM NUMBER ONE
ALLEN YOUR CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
YES I HAVE A FEELING WE'LL GET
THAT LAST ABOUT.
I'D LIKE TO RETURN TO ITEM
NUMBER.
ONE THE ALLEN BILL WHICH IS --
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED -- MADAM SECRETARY
COULD YOU READ THE MOTION AND
THEN AND THEY DE THE THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION IS AN ONLINE.
COULD YOU READ THE EMOTION AND
CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS DO YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE
[inaudible]
ROW CHIU.
CHIU I'D GRAY MAYES.
MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS NOT VOTING QUIRK
NO.
WORK NO MCCARTY. THIRTY AYE TING
BILLS ON CALL. TO IT THAT BILL
IS ON CALL IT NEEDS.
TO ALL RIGHT WILL NOW GO THROUGH
THE REST OF THE BILLS -- DATA.
ARE STILL ON CALL.
ACTUALLY WHY DON'T WE WAIT
BECAUSE MISTER CHANG IS HERE AND
THERE NUMBER OF THAT WON'T.
PASS A LET'S JUST -- WELL WHAT
WELL WHAT WOULD THE COMMITTEE
NUMBER.
TWO NUMBER.
TWO AND ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS.
SB THREE FOUR FOUR BY MISTER
MCGUIRE.
ALL RIGHT MADAM SECRETARY --
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SHE'LL.
CHIU I THIRTY AYE.
MCCARTY AYE.
EIGHTEEN OKAY THE BILL IS OUT
HAS PASSED THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND NOW WE COULD.
AND START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL RIGHT WE'LL START
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR
ADD ONS.
CHU.
CHU AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE.
COULD YOU CALL MISTER CHANG.
ARE WE HAVE THE CHAIR HERE --
FOR I AM NUMBER [inaudible]
FOUR TWO CHIU I LINDA IS MCCARTY
HI CURRY I ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
SIX TWO CHIU I MCCARTY I MCCARTY
HI.
ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT TWO CHIU I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I ITEM NUMBER NINE CHIU.
CHIU I MCCARTY.
CRAZY I ITEM NUMBER TEN CHU.
MCCARTY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN CHU.
CHU ARI.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
TWELVE TO CHIU IRA.
MCCARTY.
CARTY I'D.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN CHU.
CHIU I MCCARTY [inaudible]
HI.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN CHU.
CHU ARI.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
SHOE. TWO I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I ITEM NUMBER. SIXTEEN
TO TWO I MCCARTY MCCARTY I ITEM
NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN CHU.
CHU ARI [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN CHU.
CHU AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN CHU.
CHU ARI.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I YES GENTLEMEN YOU'RE
BOTH DONE.
THAT WAS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH YOU'VE BEEN ADDED -- TO
WHEN WHEN [inaudible]
TO OKAY.
VOTING ON THIS [inaudible]
JACKSON.
WELL MISTER CHANG WAS ABSENT
.
EVEN WITH YOU.
THE CALLING ITEM WE LIVED IN A
CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE AS BE.
FORTY THREE BURKE HI BURKE
[inaudible]
FIVE ZERO GRAY [inaudible]
MAYES.
MULLIN THIS KING OR QUEEN.
THAT MEASURE -- THE MEASURE
FAILS -- WITH -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WOULD LIKE THE
AUTHOR WOULD LIKE TO NOTICE
RECONSIDERATION.
SEEN NO OBJECTION THAT NO THIS
IS APPROVED -- LIVING A FILE
ITEM.
THREE WITH HIGHLAND -- AS BEFORE.
SIXTY EIGHT CALL THE ABSENTEES.
BURKE HI BURKE I ROLL.
MAYES MELENDEZ KING ARE.
THAT FILLS OUT AND WE CAN.
TO YEAH.
MOVING TO ADD ONS.
RESEARCHING THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
HI.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB.
THREE FOUR FOUR HI TINA I ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB FIVE THREE LASER
[inaudible]
KING I ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
SEVEN NINE ONE KING I ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB.
THIRTY FOUR EXCUSE ME.
FIVE THANK YOU.
I REMEMBER MONNING SB
[inaudible]
SIXTY THREE TING I ITEM NUMBER
TEN SB ONE NINE SIX KING OR KING
I ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN SB TWO FORTY EIGHT TING.
I YES.
EVERYTHING HAS BOILED OF COURSE
WITH THAT WE'RE ADJOURNED